foreign
pay attention focused I think we're live
maybe
super rejects you know how it goes when
Greg when Greg helping a co-host
Greg brain energy a little low in the
first couple minutes and then just give
me like 10 to 15 and we're gonna rock
and roll but you know what to do if you
are uh active in the Stream right now
please let me know are we live it looks
like we're live oh yeah I think we're
live we got some stuff to talk about
today koi I'll keep this here try not to
look at yourself too much in the card is
yeah beautiful man green and blue for
colors my favorite face what's going on
people shot some people super quick Joe
M design Mr bingleman Ron Coy help out
what are you doing I've been waiting
there's only three it's so and slow it
is we keep it inside Amber Robin West
Parker Ian blotch Matt
Downing night one two three
oh my God
Mandy's Channel leave a like on the
stream everyone leave a goddamn lie
Xavier Phoenix criminal tomato Sage only
gun uh tripathy Mohit you have done your
due diligence alrighty guys well yeah
you could see yourself here in the chat
let me just make it a tad smaller that
way okay yeah now more people can see
themselves just a little stretched out
on screen ladies gentlemen we got some
news to talk about we got a couple
topics that we have picked out ourselves
of course you know we got the Fantastic
Four news about some potential casting
and then you know there's some Jonathan
Majors updates or some news about Venom
three there's some other DCU talks but
remember you guys are the ones who
really help drive this stream based off
of your feedback based off of you know
whatever it is that you guys are Miss
mainly on your mind or you want us to
talk about streamlab super chats are
more than welcome great way to have your
question to be guaranteed to be read and
also uh thank you to everyone who
contributed last week got a ton kept
these guys live for a very long time
three hours which is a co-host an
awesome thing to get going the more they
come in the longer we stay that's the
way we roll we read every single one of
them never end the stream without doing
it but before we go into all those news
uh koi you wanted to mention a couple of
things uh I do want to talk about the
glory that is the Adam Driver news I
think at the top uh I do think that is
something that shouldn't be as it's been
the maybe the most controversial oh you
son of a b you wanted to oh I was like I
got news he said he wanted to plug
something and I set him up and he
doesn't he doesn't follow through I was
so in work mode I was so fun producing I
was focused uh this Friday you're
blocking your face yesterday you're
blocking yourself I'm gonna look at
myself I need to know where I am who I
am this Friday the 28th if you're in La
if you're in Southern California
especially if you're in Burbank Flappers
and Burbank we're gonna be doing a
stand-up show followed by an episode of
capes and cowls a lot of people said
they wanted to see my stand up I'm doing
a full 10 minute set on Friday you are
I'm doing yeah I'm doing like a tight 10
dude who else is going to be there it's
gonna be Roxy stryer Winston Marshall
Christian harloff Kate Mulligan and uh I
think Steph surprise is coming so we got
a nice onslaught of the Shmoe Community
but not all of us are doing stand up me
Winston Christian doing stand-up I
believe Kate is as well and then there's
going to be an episode of capes and cows
an episode of The Big Thing an episode
of Sith Council so tickets are on sale
now the christianharloff.com and they
are almost sold out so I'd get in there
uh they I think are they almost sold out
it's the rooms over three quarters sold
and I don't know how big the room is so
I think that it's almost sold out
um yeah it's only so many seats there's
a lot of people go there's a show that I
I know I feel like
I mean it's a Friday it's a Friday night
starts 10 p.m so it's late enough you
might get your work done 10 p.m in the
morning you're an adult
thank you for that Super Chat uh by the
way over who was that we're we're doing
we'll get to everyone's Super Chat I
promise when they come in but thank you
for being the first Super Chat yeah can
you guys hear this noise no Yuka prida
why can't I hear it I don't know where's
John okay you know I know John right now
John's making the noise that's what
happens when you press that button
we'll make our own noises when someone
comes in it's gonna be great alrighty
guys well let's kick it off let's talk
about the main thing that other people
have been talking about this week and
also be sure to leave a like on this
video uh that helps with the playback
here uh I what is the first thing we
want to talk about Adam Driver it looks
like he is the front runner to be my
original tangent yes yes to be the front
runner for
um uh Reed Richards in the Fantastic
Four and here were my thoughts I want to
get I want to say them quick because I
think they're more profound
that sounds good
I don't I feel like Adam Driver can do
it he can do anything there you go she's
going to take it away actor Ryan act why
is Adam Driver well you know what I'll
say uh I think Adam Driver is good
because I think when some people think
of ree Richards if I'm not super
familiar with Reed Richards I'm not like
the most you know informative McCoy will
recommend me some stuff and then I'll be
able to really get my knowledge down uh
but I Reed Richards has a Darkness to
him you know and I think Adam Driver can
bring that level of uh of a strong
protagonist someone who can have that
warmth you could be endeared to him but
also
provide that like Darkness underneath
the eyes that Adam driver's so good at
bringing to like every single role
because he seems like a moody individual
yeah and that's like something that I
and it just brings a level of uh impact
and gravitas to like every performance
he does and I think for him to be back
in the mouse house is a cool thing
I love all that I completely agree but
you hate it uh no actually I think this
is a great opportunity for John Oliver
to Cameo no I I really love uh have you
seen the John Oliver oh yeah yeah yeah
crushed me thick Daddy yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's why I want now John Oliver
and as on Oliver uh no I think that it's
a really interesting uh take because it
shows a lot of what the age of the
Fantastic Four is going to be if this is
true this gives us kind of a window of
you know how old our Sue and our jobs
I'll just sit like this baby in a car
seat just you don't don't you worry
buddy so I think that it gives us a
sense of the age of the team and it's
not going to be that young mistake they
made with the reboot it's also not going
to be too old where they can't play
these characters for the next 10 to 15
years read has those you know Dusty gray
sides but you can get those in your 30s
it's been interesting to see people be
like he's too young I'm like bro he's
39. look at that that's a grown man uh
but I I think what it says is there's
going to be an element of the Council of
reads that's established in the
beginning where there is a Darkness
underneath where there is an element of
he's a man cursed with pure Brilliance
and he gets frustrated he's
absent-minded he's a family man but he's
also I'm really a family man with his
work I'm like that's what he loves so I
want to see Reed be able to do what like
the marriage story elements of Adam
Driver was where it's really
multifaceted there's a lot going on
there's a lot of depth to the
performance but also the levity of
things like the SNL that he did or
um the the heart of things like his Noah
bombach films like I think his resume
really speaks to what he can bring to
read and I love some of the other
choices like Penn Badgley and and names
that were bandied about but I think Adam
Driver has a bank ability of Gravitas
and the versatility as an actor that's
required and I think he's a really good
choice
he's a man in a metal mask again in a
cloak yeah I'm on the same page as you
brother
um yeah the the the thing with Adam
Driver is like I've seen some people
here who are saying like they can't see
him as Reed Richards and we got a good
amount of super jets thank you guys yeah
thank you we will get to all of them
don't worry we read every single one of
them
um the the thing with Adam Driver that I
think will happen with anyone who's
doubting is the second you see that
first trailer hell even the first image
they're probably going to be like never
mind I was wrong correcty looks great
someone was bringing it up in the chat
earlier uh they wonder if he's gonna cut
his hair for it
because yeah every time I see the cat
fan casting I imagine it'll be like
somewhere between his long hair to his
uh his his
um
I mean like okay we have we the fan the
fan pick that I put in the thumbnail
that's kind of like I think so that's
like the length that I would imagine it
to be yeah and I think they're gonna get
the sides right and give them that
little graying and I think it's gonna
get more pronounced as the series goes
on I think yeah I think you know in the
comics how uh in the comic movie said
they get more and more comic accurate
with their costumes that'll just be his
hair yeah but she's gonna get more comic
accurate as he stresses yeah yeah I'm
excited for that but yeah there we go so
Mila Kunis I think is going to be Sue
that is one of the top that supposedly
that is like the top picks for Sue storm
and it works age-wise and it works like
the what the style of them uh I'm very
surprised by that just from knowing Mila
Kunis uh personally yeah called her up
comes over here she's gonna be in your
flapper show oh yeah so maybe look
uh Mila Kunis
just she's already got this like a
career of residual income yeah all
around from That 70s Show to Family Guy
she's gotten into making movies and
producing herself she's like a great
producer she has an entire production
company where she like green lights
projects that I've actually I've met
with Mila Kunis about a project and
she's so invested in the Hands-On that
she's at every meeting for her whole
company and she really cares about the
final product impact on the people she
wants to know what the reaction the
people are going to have to it before
she even goes to step one so that means
the script's got to be great I mean what
Matt Chapman's predicting like for this
to be his SPX this is like a 10-year
commitment I don't see her doing it
unless it's great well that's that was
one thing is like I she only does things
right now that she is really personally
drawn to like she doesn't need money
that's something
with Ashton Kutcher doing okay woman
really doesn't need money they're okay
but and I think Mila Kunis is also an
underrated actress as well like I agree
we mainly know her for her comedic work
but she have you seen American Psycho
too nailed
magnum opus
that was a good one uh we do got to get
to some super chats in just a second
don't worry we will get to all them but
um I did want to quickly touch on the
Jonathan major stuff because I just want
to get out of the way because people
have been asking for us about videos uh
since you know so we did a video talking
about it and then within the matter of
48 hours two more pieces of news did
break out regarding Jonathan majors and
we didn't we just didn't do it because
it got to the point where I was like you
know what
just wait let's just wait a video you
should probably just wait for a while
right and um so the first thing that
came out was that there were multiple uh
multiple women have apparently are
cooperating with the D.A district
attorney uh bringing more allegations
towards Jonathan Majors moment from his
past presumably and then um Jonathan
Majors his lawyer the following day
finally released some uh showing
that the woman at the bar where there
were reports uh that the girlfriend
reports about like her did you follow
all this
um well refresh my memory here basically
she was out that night and and there was
video of her like you know because like
where her injury was she was using the
thing where her supposedly her and
apparently the images didn't match with
the Strangling marks that were
apparently you know yes there were
discrepancies in what we had heard
versus what was shown versus what was
said is what I gathered yeah yeah and
like I remember when those text messages
came out and even in our video we did
say like this could totally be a person
in just a toxic abusive relationship
maybe she is right or we could just be
reading way too much into it and maybe
she is just being very straightforward
about it right yeah like we just don't
we don't know because everything is an
allegation at this point and I think
that's really important on this
conversation because I've seen so many
tick tocks so many videos so many actual
credible news sites talking about this
as if there's anything in pen or
anything that's actually fact yet no we
know nothing and May 8th I think is the
first court date so I think it's really
I I think this will be really gross if
it becomes the next Johnny Depp Amber
Heard and I know that people like a
circus and I know that people like to
watch people that they see as famous or
Rich fail and I think it's going to be a
really detrimental thing to society if
we keep going hey that real life problem
we should make a spectacle and profit
off it because I know entire YouTube
channels that literally people bought
houses off of commenting on famous
people's plights and it's disgusting I
mean you're ready if this thing doesn't
work out boom just bam Amber Heard
Johnny Depp trial coverage too drama all
the way just watching reactions to the
trailers like to the terms of the trial
blame it all on the left stream virtue
signaling culture
look how mad I am isolate a line or two
from something yell at the screen he
jokes High profit but like that is a
high profit honestly if you didn't have
souls oh my God yeah our articulation
Well we'd be the best worst lawyers
but it's important to separate but yeah
important in terms of the Jonathan major
stuff it's like one thing that this
thing can get so sticky because
yeah I mean when you see when you hear
about oh there's strangulation marks and
then you see the close-up body cam
footage and you don't see a
strangulation Mark you go okay maybe
this to get blown out proportion because
the lawyer is saying that part of the
video evidence is that you could see
that the cops were pretty much
suggesting that she says that you know
like kind of forcing The Narrative to go
that way and then you got people from
because it could be it could very well
be both things it could very well be he
didn't actually harm her and then he he
could have also have been abusive in the
past but how far in the past was that
did he make has he changed enough as a
person for those things to not be you
know something he should be condemned
for and also you know we said 11 women
or whatever the number was oh my God 11.
that's what I heard 11. but that's a lot
of that's a lot of people and also the
thing is these are not just people going
on Twitter and like those are
things but like I do think there's an
element of like every time you watch a
movie and there's a crime all these
people struggling with the police
station like I saw the guy there is an
element of people wanting to be part of
the the circus as well that said even if
it's one of
but I'm saying like I don't know how
much of this is overblown because of the
scale of Jonathan Major's star power
like I'm saying 11 people is the rumor
we don't know if all of them are true
but if even if one of them is true
that's horrible and true shouldn't be
going forward the bottom line is we
can't draw a conclusion until we know
anything yeah so uh and the thing is
he's such a big part of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and that's why he's
in our conversation so much yeah because
literally this whole thing has been
revolving around his character so it's
just an Avengers movie named after him
coming up in 2026. yeah so following the
whole thing about what's going on with
him is not just like like even when the
giant death trial is happening we once
in a while talked about it Jonathan
Majors one is like a big impact for this
whole franchise which is ongoing
it's not like Johnny Depp was doing
Pirates five that day like it's it's or
whatever pirate throw but then you know
reportedly Jonathan a 20 million dollar
payday saw that for King Dynasty but I
think that's deserved if you have like
five movies to revolve around you but
who knows if uh if he's like really I
don't know what the how people are going
to feel about having to prove his case
against the multiple allegations that
are being set with the D.A but I think
all that really matters to people right
now is the situation with the girlfriend
I I think right now it's John versus
public Persona like I I think that like
sure it's not John Humphrey John
Humphrey he's not John Humphrey Jonathan
Majors versus okay look at the chat like
the chat is literally like innocent
until we're beginning there's three
people being like yeah but they dropped
him from all those projects I pr he
might have fired because they did a
horrible job yeah uh the management team
might have just been like we are dealing
with so many things we don't want to be
anywhere near this the movie's dropping
it might have been because like they
don't feel like they could get them the
movies moving in time with all this
negative press we don't know any facts
yet like those that's me Playing devil's
advocate to the fact that this town is
gonna knee-jerk react to things we don't
know anything so I think it's it's messy
to say otherwise oh yeah but uh worst
case Jonathan Majors is out I would say
uh Finn wolfhard is ready he's ready
he's born for this uh Jensen Ackles for
Batman I would love to see Jensen Ackles
playing old man Batman I think if they
did Batman Beyond he would be great to
do it if you guys seen high top films is
uh Batman Beyond video amazing
watch I do like singles for Batman
quite a bit
um all right so before we go to
superchastic One More Story we want to
knock out here but here's what I'm going
to do I'm gonna I'm gonna mix this up a
tie a bit here guys I'm gonna mix this
up watch Greggy go to work I'm trying I
was experimenting here with obs obs
so watch koi looking watching I'm
excited if I can uh figure this out a
lot of buttons happening now we're
looking we got space left monitor we are
in the same room oh my God watch
everyone I'm gonna is that why everyone
can read with us
and not be small
[Laughter]
there it is we're becoming a real live
stream show look at our power koi
scooching closer to me thanks buddy
all right well I just gotta do some
adjusting here and then we're good to go
look at that oh my God we can actually
see what's going on here
so he shocked for us look at his face
there's been a back and forth here of
um
how about having
what is this person
you
it's Saturday morning
what do you want everybody that's so
ridiculous
man looks comfortable I'm jealous
frankly next time I'm coming in PJs dude
I've worked for like 10 15 hour days I'm
gonna wear my PJs yeah so anyway guys
the and these are from me undies
alrighty guys so here's the thing here's
the thing all right so we want to talk
about the Henry Cavill uh upcoming DC
movie Cameo because apparently he's this
Cameo is back in this film but it's not
the one that he shot for the movie it's
it's the different cut one that sets
something up and they're like let's put
something in yeah they've put something
completely different in there and what
they put in there which is kind of
surprising to me because I thought like
the one way to kind of like soften the
blow but I believe this is from Casey
Walsh who is a uh well like this this
scooper is often pretty good at scooping
uh they said that Capital does appear in
the speed force but it's just repurposed
Justice League footage not the big
surprise and they did get rid of that
scene that he did she the new scene
which is so bizarre to be that they
would get rid of footage they got rid of
that new scene but
um and from my understanding what I've
read is that the footage that they have
in there is from the a Justice League so
it's that it's the Sprints it's the I I
don't know I mean they might have they
it's all green screen so they could
have just easily like isolated something
out and put it there when he's like
flying or whatever footage he used but
yeah apparently the footage is there
from the Justice League one and not from
like he would be in the sofa he'd be in
the black suit maybe if they wanted to
make it Zack Snyder's Justice League and
I feel like one way to have softened the
blow a tad bit is just make it the Zach
make sure it's the zacksiders Justice
League one yeah at least give that
little sign off like let him have
something I mean hey green screen
mustache it's coming back and I wonder
if how Henry Cavill would feel about
them just using him after they have
electives right so they can't you can't
really they can't just use him can't
they yeah 100 said like oh damn they own
his voices look as long as he was on set
getting paid for those times that is all
Theirs to use in perpetuity in
throughout the universe is the contracts
now which is scary because when we
establish Life on Mars they can use that
footage this poor guy just tossed around
he really is just tossed around bad uh
but I think he watches his movie Man of
Steel get remade as well in this film
I feel for him because I know how much
he loves the character and it's really
messy to go film for a movie to not use
that and then use other things that's
just dark but I mean this is getting
flashes getting screened at cinemacon so
we're gonna hear uh far too much and the
fact that they are screening it that
early yeah shows like their confidence
they got a confidence in this movie man
I'm just like we're gonna know literally
every Cameo by Wednesday yeah and that's
a bummer like the the people that aren't
in Vegas are gonna know the whole movie
before they see it in a month uh which
is up yeah like the internet's
not gonna be chill it's like really oh
man it's a mess well guys are you
excited for Henry Cavill to return leave
your thoughts in the comments below
alrighty guys well let's get to it let's
get to it all right we got 970 viewers
thank you so much for being here hell
yeah Saturday morning
um I I want to be so next week we got a
Flash trailer though yeah
and by the way guys koi is going to be
gone for uh several days
uh is that a for sure thing 99
um that's that's the first weeks of May
though so I'll be here for a little bit
all right well let's catch up on some
super chest since we're definitely
behind here thank you guys so much for
contributing thank you it pays for Coy
to be here yeah it all goes to koi 100
even though YouTube takes 50 yeah they
do take a not just about you know what
let's try a different thing on this is
you know when we're going we just like
to mess around here let's just see if we
can shine even a bigger light on what
you guys have done all right all right
Coy let's try this out let's try this
out oh oh we're gonna be able to
see everyone's questions big loud and
clear don't worry I got this handled
there it is there it is it's going great
I got this handled because we definitely
need to catch up and then I just need to
lower it and and boom and then we're set
solid oh my God Yoda fault so then
that's just uh koi filling the gaps here
while I'm trying to so the
thing about Adam Driver
is you allow that to set up the uh
villain of the Ultimate Universe which
is a lot of what the Marvel Cinematic
Universe is based off of leading to an
incursion event which is the plot of
secret or the comic from 2015 which may
be the plot of secret War so they could
be setting stuff up really early to
allow for multiple reads and I think
that's really interesting by having
someone as versatile as Adam Driver all
right so what's the best way to do this
koi if we do it like that yeah then you
can read the bottom one yeah then start
the bottom one oh yeah okay then we go
and then I could highlight it so then
you guys know what question we're on
Boom see because most people I know
watch from the phone all right so this
gives me a little vertical thing I like
that oh my God then we can make this
even super chaotic whoa
let's have everything there's so many
comments
[Music]
what's the point of even having the chat
there or what are these tiny people
reading this tiny font about all right
Teague Teague what is Teague saying now
you don't have to look over here
okay all right I could look over Eric uh
teak thank you so much for the Super
Chat hip hip hooray koi are you excited
for the Venture Brothers movie what is
your favorite Adult Swim show we're
keeping this about comic books Aqua Teen
frisky dingo Morel Oriel Super Jail
Etc you got two minutes on the clock koi
take it away it's gonna be less than
that I'm gonna be totally completely
honest I am not a venture brothers guy
uh I don't watch a lot of uh TV that is
not uh like in the in the what's that
what do we got oh is that a timer oh
yeah there's so many variables uh I
don't watch a lot of like I don't have a
lot of time for TV so I generally watch
the biggest show of the Season like I
love Ted lasso but that's now become the
thing that I can report on um Venture
Brothers never really captured me
animation doesn't really connect with me
like I like Miyazaki but it doesn't make
me cry like all my friends like I just
animation for whatever reason there's a
there's a disconnect for me uh and I
really really don't watch a lot of
Comedy um the reason I love Banshee so
much is it made me laugh like I think a
lot of other people enjoy comedy comedy
doesn't really like register for me I'm
like a Broken Man animation and comedy
don't settle so I've never seen an
episode of Venture Brothers but uh I
know that Adult Swim is responsible for
a lot of the great John schnep's work so
uh anything Adult Swim does I respect
because they they brought John schnep's
art to life I just don't personally
connect to animation or a lot of Comedy
which is a sad way to live way to go koi
you did it you did it in one minute
thank you so much all right here we go
oh my God I do like the look of this
it's like Shane black comic but I like
dark oh I run into a little problem here
like I love this I need to refresh this
oh no it's it's experiment with imagery
here but okay I've learned how to
free-form this around so we this is jazz
guys it's happening around happening in
real time is how we roll around here
right now we sell one on the sacks she's
going for it
Bill Burgess Stanley I agree Republic of
casuals I think every Stanley Cameo
should be replaced by Bill Burks he's
the best part of Star Wars now oh look
Planet boss this is so good okay we've
got too far let's just read old Super
Chat let's do it let's talk about what
John would say any questions we got this
um
oh no I skipped I totally skipped some
questions Smokey vandros I like my I
like stand-up comedy more than like
televised comedy and I like comedy
movies and TV like once but I don't find
I re-watch them and I also find that
like comedy's so subjective that usually
what I find funny most people don't like
my two favorite comedies or Kiss Kiss
Bang Bang and Bruges and those aren't
the type of comedies that like most
people make
I believe you all right so this was
actually the first super challenge and I
totally messed this up uh this was our
first one I would have waited yeah we
said this name I know we said you're the
first one and I totally skipped you so
sorry I had we're learning here yuca
priete
thank you between you guys comic story
and you rock stars you guys make my life
better if you look here's koi let's try
that let's try this look right there you
can you guys make my life better love
you all keep doing what you are doing
best DC EU movie you know what I'm gonna
put it out there um I think the suicide
squad is my favorite one I've seen all
of them multiple times and as much as I
love I do love the Snyder Trilogy and I
oh my God we got a massive Super Chat
holy wow thank you so much it
doesn't happen when Jones around here
they know we're gonna pocket it
history
just the butt of every Financial joke
but I would say thank you so much uh
Comics turning Rockstar okay I rewatched
I'm a big fan of Love is Blind only
reality show I watch koi knows we were
shooting something very special uh it's
a big work in progress and then I was
telling the crew I gotta get home I've
got a heart out I feel like a serious
like we're going overtime already and I
need to get back to watch Love is Blind
reunion that didn't work out I don't
know if you guys saw on Twitter it was a
mad house I've never seen Greg so
excited like not a trailer not a movie
or at least not like literally we're
working on something brand new it's like
guys I've got roughly two hours I was in
a room with a small crew of people and I
was telling them all like guys I was
trying to sell them all on like he was
pitching start love is blind and and
then and then it wasn't working after
several hours so I just rewatched the
suicide squad and I was like God damn
this movie is perfect like to me
it's perfect and like everyone has their
own preference if you prefer Zack
Snyder's Justice League if you prefer
Wonder Woman or whatever it may might be
but to me I feel like that is like the
perfect run time it's so impressive to
me the amount of characters that they
introduce there and yet you still feel
like you really they there's like almost
they like while there's some good
Exposition in there there's also a semi
like impressive laconic way of handling
the impact you can have on characters
with doing little and yet same time
doing a lot you know so I think it's I I
love that film I just think it's so
entertaining and I'm I'm weirdly moved
to tears whatever The Suicide Squad
decides to jump into the battlefield to
fight staro yeah and just watching that
so yeah you know I think it's really
great uh what's your favorite DCU film
uh first of all thanks for the love to
all those channels uh and mine I believe
is I think actually the first Shazam uh
I get a lot out of found family stories
I think that's surprising yeah is it
well I love I love family that's why I
love the fast family but I also love
that you know family's thicker than
blood and I think a lot of foster
stories make the Foster families like
evil because there's a lot of you know
Brokenness in any system there's a lot
of corruption in any system but there's
also the good side in any system and I
feel like when you say like foster
parent the instinct is this knee-jerk
reaction of like evil corrupt profit and
instead Shazam made this really lovely
story of an underdog and finding a
family and then finding a superhero
family I love the mirroring of finding
his Billy Batson family and his shazamly
I love the mirroring of what the lack of
family did to the evil the corruption
versus what this kid with nothing found
that is more important this money I love
the idea of the the sins being the
manifestation of the darkness that he
has to like leave behind there's just a
lot in that first movie that really
speaks to me and I also I think the
reason we love uh superheroes is that
child like wondering Glee and I think in
the first film it works a lot better
with Zach playing a you know 12 14 year
old and being that like ridiculous over
the top and there's like there's just
this in it I also think it was my least
expected to be that good like there was
DC was on a roller coaster of quality
and then Shazam no one was counting on
and then I saw it like two months early
because I toured with it and I was like
this movie's gonna like be everywhere
and then it did well considering like no
one knew the character no one knew David
F Sandberg it just that one means a lot
to me I love The Suicide Squad but I
think my my experience with Shazam and
my history with it is my number one
I'm gonna let walkie stay in the chat my
block I say yeah he's the guy saying
this about my clothes and you know
everybody gets part of my brand all week
everybody well it's almost like he has a
washer and dryer in his house because he
lives here like why would you
have do you own something different show
man oh yeah it's also like he lives here
and has to like does this look like a
lazy man right here
those games don't happen from doing
laundry in your own home
hi from Croatia love your reactions and
videos thank you so much I love Croatia
I visit there twice a year best pizza in
the in the world Jeremy Castle on the
other hand can go himself Corey
forgot sake take your meds it's like the
third time he's attempted that I just
have energy because I take care of
myself so uh I don't know what meds you
want me to take but I'm not gonna
your mother koi please
you don't need to have sex with anyone's
mother here it depends on the mother
that it does
have you seen Coy's mom
should I walked right into that I was
unprepared Chef Carol Jeff Carroll here
we go I missed the old koi
Corey you gotta learn to just laugh at
them and not engage too diff they're
trying to propose the old coin the old
I've always hated people being
Jeff Carroll hey hey Jeff Carroll sent
two super chats here hello hello hello
I could read here I usually try to Fan
cast to my own ideas and not just agree
with the internet but I agree with
Giancarlo Esposito as Professor X last
year I saw his panel at a convention
when he
answered questions he turned them into
something inspirational he made me want
to be a better man to lead through
kindness and compassion is why he's
perfect for Xavier truly incredible
I want Giancarlo Esposito to come and
play a because people have said Doctor
Doom for him as well well I think John
Carlo will be a great pick I'm gonna set
a timer for us here well I think it'd be
a great pick at the same time I've sick
of seeing him play bad guys I'm really
really sick of him playing bad guys it
gets to the point where it's not as
intimidating as it once was it's not Gus
ring anymore even with Gus Fring and by
taking him and I haven't seen it by
taking him into Better Call Saul they
gotta shine more light on him where he
wasn't just viewed as a villain anymore
they he was in some ways like I would
say definitely he's one of the
protagonists of the show and I thought
he was excellent and I want to see more
of him so the idea of him playing
Professor X I think would be a great
pick I think it'd be way more
interesting he wants to play yeah what
do you think about him playing Professor
X personally I think Professor X has a
more uh broad tapestry for someone that
hasn't touched on those things I think
he's gotten stuck in a very specific
like stoic villainy drawl like the The
Wave in his voice comes out has that
whereas if you've met him and seen him
at panels he's Joy incarnate Giancarlo
is one of the most giving exuberant
Lively people we don't get to see that
on screen a lot if you look at his old
work like Malcolm X if you look at his
work like you know do like the the do
the right thing era Giancarlo I really
think that there's a lot of uh like Joy
Diva he's got a zest for life he doesn't
get to show a lot I think Xavier can
have that like we've seen with mcavoy's
and Patrick Stewart's but also there is
like we talked about earlier when on
Heron inherent Darkness like Reed has
the reason Onslaught happens is a
combination of Magneto and Xavier
creating this literal uh existential
crisis of a character called Onslaught
that destroys the planet and kills all
the Marvel heroes but that's from
Xavier's psyche so there's an
underpinning of Darkness that I think
Giancarlo would play better than just
pure darkness and I'd love to see him
get a chance to also show that Joy so I
think he's a way better choice for that
than personally for Magneto I agree Coy
those are great answers koi I love to
hear it I love to hear it
lana.org Lana you have been here for so
long I appreciate your prayer and so
much thank you for being you along the
whole organization person you're an
amazing person
Lana says
curious who would you two cast as the F4
if you could cast anyone digging Greg's
hipster Rambo look by the way actually
you know what's funny my new look I like
to mix up my look you know sometimes
it's a hat for like six months then it's
a beanie for like six months now now I
got it now I got this I don't get made
fun of a lot for it but I'm like I don't
care
um and a brand great but tonight I'm
going with my wife uh Olivia to a
special
um a roller uh rink yeah for scream and
um I'm not and I feel like a headband
look is perfect for that I love that for
you and I don't know how to roller blade
you've never I've tried many times I am
the dumbass on the wall who's like
Shuffle Shuffle I I I have no balance so
she's buying me some rollerblades to try
to learn before I go because I've tried
many times I can't do it that is the
cutest Day Ever yeah
all right I know what I'm doing today
canceling my afternoon plans
I appreciate that but anyway let's set a
timer here who would you cast in The
Fantastic Four
um who cast as them well I think for
Reed Richards
God you know who do I really love okay
if it could just be anyone and anyone
I'm gonna go here I don't care how
inaccurate of a pick it is I would say
Ryan Gosling is Reed Richards for the
thing I would go Dave Bautista for Sue
storm I would go Emily Blunt for the
Human Torch I would go
um uh let's throw a wild card in here
the
match at a strange improv show
I'm gonna go uh Glenn Howerton is Reed
Richards I'm gonna go uh and I'm not
kidding I think he'd be excellent he has
the the both intelligence way of
speaking and also pompacity of of his
arrogance which I think would suit read
uh I'm gonna go uh Joe Kiri or Zac Efron
depending on the age they go for for
Johnny Storm I think Joe keery has an
inherent like Swoon hair flip uh you
know the the the Johnny Storm has to be
like something that makes the first
family approachable and that he's the
rock star of them so even when things go
wrong he represents that like fun of
being uh one of this this family that's
different between them and the mutants
is Johnny Storm really anchors that so I
think Joe carrier or Zac Efron I think
for the thing uh Seth Rogen because you
want the thing to have uh this
impossible charm that even though he's a
scary thing covered in rocks when you
hear him you're comforted and I could
hear him being like I hear Seth Rogen
saying it's clobber in time and being
like the thing working uh and then uh
either I know uh what you're typing here
is is funny because it's true but I
think there's a reason these archetypal
characters uh Jody Comer as Sue storm I
think after the last duel um more people
should have hired Jody Comer for
everything I think she's incredibly
intelligent incredibly versatile and you
want someone that's an intellectual
equal to read but also is a little bit
more powerful in her what her powers can
do I think Jody Comer can do that in
Rufus soul for Doctor Doom brilliant
that's why they pay the big bucks
running two seconds left genius absolute
genius
um yeah I do have a rejects headband do
you uh it's in development right I got a
prototype out there yeah
there's people testing headbands
and people like no I do have too loose I
did say like no it's a little tooth it's
too thin oh it's like I obviously wear
them a little thick you want the
graphics I want it thick here and then
the graphic in the center I like it yeah
and it literally came from me where are
these a lot so Now's the Time to Brand
It Aditya tripathi
guess what I am glad that I got
introduced to koi through your channel
finally someone finally got introduced
to you just love to watch this comic
Corner rankings and volume seven oh I
was thinking uh when you watch Guardians
you should do a ranking at the Guardians
I got a question question for the chat
um I'm gonna put this on the Community
page later to really get a a concrete
answer I wanted I want to I want to get
a Spam yes if you agree spam no if you
don't think this should be for the
ranking of Guardians of the Galaxy
movies after watching volume three
should Avengers Infinity war and end
game be included spam yes if you think
it should be included spam no if you
don't think it should be included let's
wait this out a tiny bit let's just
start let's wait let's wait because
there's a delay on the chat and it'll be
a delay on the chat okay here it comes
we'll know insane we'll wait we'll wait
so a ranking comic corner is the theory
the idea yeah yeah no it'd be fun for
the Guardians yeah I love that idea
don't worry let's just sit here in
silence let's just awkwardly just just
see what happens all right no one
actually there's a glitch no no no no
don't no all right I was surprised
because I feel like Infinity war is such
an integral part of the uh Journey
especially especially Infinity
especially Infinity War but it looks
like way more nose all right just the
three this is a cause this is a pretty
existence
wow that's an explicit that's surprising
because I think in in Infinity War the
Guardians is so such an important part I
agree it's like Guardians literally
that's when Gamora dies it doesn't
matter spoilers uh I guess no wow that's
surprising like yeah I mean I feel like
you'd have to do end game though if you
do Infinity War right that someone said
paired together not separate Noah Noah
Hall said maybe actually yeah that might
not be a bad idea but quality they're so
different though yeah that's a hard so
in game that doesn't as guardian Centric
it's more like they're I mean it has
elements there's nebula's Journey though
right oh man that's what I mean in
Guardians so that's I mean their
character Journeys are so important
there so I feel like there's an argument
to be made for why but what do you think
I should do four and pair Infinity war
and Guardians and then then Guardians
one through three as a holiday special
too oh we have to include that because
it is it is like three years counts yeah
okay man that's gonna be hard okay how
about how about we don't include
Infinity war and end game but we include
Thor love and thunder oh actually yeah
to the entire experience but they also
clearly number one that's gonna ruin the
whole rank uh but thank you Aditya that
really means a lot uh and koi I'm sure
appreciates it but I appreciate more on
Coy's behalf obviously he feels more
than I do just in general Louis Berry
all right we got some we got four picks
here from Louie all right here we go
just I'm gonna I'm gonna briefly put
away the chats uh so everyone could just
see all the pics let me just slide me to
the left here
so Louis Berry is saying here got four
picks Fantastic Four driver is a better
fit for Doom hope JK is read John
Krasinski oh I was like Simmons Emily
Blunt I want pictures of Doctor Doom and
we want to sue Taryn Edgerton is Johnny
Joel edgertonous thing Michael
Fassbender is Jim out of the four picks
for Sue Jody Comer for me these are all
great picks honestly uh Joel Edgerton
has been my uh thing for at least 10
years since Warrior uh wow almost 15.
but uh I've recently with some of Seth
Rogen's like dramatic work in the
fablemans and with the bank ability I do
think there's going to be an element of
needing to make sure that your actors
are both talented as well as marketable
um that is a factor I think it's so
funny and people are like we need all
unknowns and I'm like yeah but movies
cost money uh and I think that that Seth
Rogen has a bank ability I think Joel
Edgerton it would be perfect depending
on who you cast around him but I do
think you also need to make this uh you
need to recover 250 million dollars at a
time so I I both of them would work for
me for very different reasons uh but I
love all these very much Michael
Fassbender is Doom uh is a great way to
bring him back in a non-magnito way uh
and yeah love all your takes the
description box for the live stream is
keyword Bonanza
it really does help all those keywords
help for the um for the playback too
because live streams are a little bit
harder to get pushed in algorithm on
playback and we're trying to do more of
these to catch up on all the news so if
you guys want more of these we need to
know and I also I also want one day for
koi to host it by himself bringing it
back it's gonna be me on the ones and
twos and pressing colors and reading and
Chaos it's the legit goal here that
we're aiming for right now
thank you so much name your Harry Potter
HBO cast so many characters with big
shoes to fill we'll just do the main
three we'll do the main three okay
to feel it's going to be hard Adam
Driver Snape though I mean that's right
there that's a solid pick
um I would say
for Harry hear me out here hear me out
here are my picks Ryan Gosling Emily
Blunt for Hermione obviously and then
um
and you know what it would be so hard
for it's so hard for me to do a Harry
Potter HBO I know a lot of 10 year olds
that's exactly what I was thinking it
was because I'm like I don't know any
kids
I don't follow like children who have to
age over the course of 10 years I don't
know what a lot of British TV where kids
have been around if you can't do like
legal 18 year olds to play because they
all they they literally have to they
have to age this for like 10 years which
is like bananas to me
um that what a commitment to ask from
children I will say Brendan Gleason to
be a great Hagrid yeah he was already in
the Harry Potter movie doesn't mean he
can't come back differently just asked
Ralph boner he was he was in the Harry
Potter movie he was mad Eye Moody but he
could also be a great Haggard now that
he's a little older true I think it'd be
great but I can't think of any kids like
I'm so sorry to disappoint utkarsh but
like I can't I honestly think you're uh
Adam Driver of Snape though is a good
pick pretty inspired I feel like he
would be oh man that would be so I think
not no one is more iconic than than um
Alan Rickman a Snape I think Beyond I
think that's why that casting's been so
hard every other cast member there like
I'd be excited to see a different take
Snape is the one where wow it'd be
really hard to not
it's like compare it to Alex I love the
cast in the original but as a fan of the
books I really am hoping for a different
uh flavor of Dumbledore as it evolves I
feel like the dumbled like the did you
put your name on The Goblet when in the
book it's written as like Harry he asks
calmly did you put your name in The
Goblet like there's a lot of different
takes uh with that Dumbledore so I'm I'm
personally really curious of who the
cast is Dumbledore yeah I think that uh
I think what Aisha said in the chat is
just a cast all unknowns again I think I
I think you need to cast
um like uh historic actors as the
teachers but I do think the kids can be
unknown because they kind of need to
grow into the roles exactly Kiana Chanel
top picks for a new king thank you Kiana
uh for the Super Chat means a lot if
that's what's going to happen John
boyega Albus Hodge and weird but it
works Marlon Wayans I died it doesn't
work does it work two minutes koi I'm
became a comprehend Marlon Wayans I
can't comprehend him um I actually think
Elvis Hodges a king is a I also think
he's available I thought he's definitely
available he can't even be in Shazam
Aldous Hodge is legitimately one of the
most talented actors that isn't as big
of a name as he should be like when he
was in um The Invisible Man I was like
now is his time because I've been a fan
of eldest Hodge for a long time and I
feel like he's one of those 20-year
overnight successes if you look at his
resume he's been great forever I want
him I wanted Hawkman to be his Superman
I wanted it to be his big break I would
love if if we find out concretely we
need to recast
I do think he's an excellent choice of a
deserved actor to be someone that's
literally Avengers Kang Dynasty that
name needs to be someone worthy and I
love aldisod so that's my pick of those
I think John boyega deserves a franchise
Redemption I'd love to see him come back
in the um Rey Star Wars thing that they
announced I'd love to see him get to
continue his Arc as a stormtrooper Jedi
like they didn't land the thing they
promised I want four boyega that
Redemption so if it's not going to be in
Star Wars I'd love to see him get it in
a Marvel property again uh that's more
about like me wanting the actor to be
happy with franchise Redemption and how
he's treated but uh I I like either of
Aldous or boyega yeah yeah especially I
think if you go like too famous of a guy
that might be even a little bit more
distracting Denzel like I I actually
even thought when it came to the whole
which I didn't
um agree with uh with with recasting
Johnny Depp in crimes of Grindelwald I
actually did think
mads Mickelson was the right caliber of
Fame to replace like Fame plus talent to
supplement for Johnny Depp I thought
that was a good pick I thought they
should have gone back to Colin Farrell
because it was already there yeah they
already had a guy that wasn't Johnny
Depp playing a character like we know
Circle yeah but I but that's what I mean
I feel like uh Aldous Hodge is actually
like kind of in that in that perfect
bracket yeah for my for my personal pick
but yeah really talented guy too but I
think boyoga does a deserve a chance at
uh Star Wars again to do good to do
right by him Mustafa jav what adult
actor would you cast in the MCU and what
roles no shame everyone watches porn I
actually haven't seen porn in quite a
while I can actually that's what we
talked about that
[Laughter]
um
so uh oh what adult act who are some
adult actors I Used to Know
okay mine are all like old adult actors
sure Asa Akira
and uh oh Sasha Gray Sasha Grace herself
to be like she's very actually a good
actor yeah she'd be Emma Frost Sasha
Tasha gray and that's not a bad pick at
all I think her or Polaris like as
Polaris or Emma Frost Sasha Gray yeah
uh there's a lot of sexy X-Men so like I
feel like a very sexy guy if we want to
just go back to actually you know what
if they wanted to go back to like just
the super sexy revealing kind of Suits
yeah we're just like the woman just had
their breasts exposed back yeah then if
you wanted to get
I actually can't think of a lot of adult
important like like workers I can't
think of a lot of sex workers that are
like uh
uh I've never even seen one in person
I'm friends I'm trying to think of like
I'm friends with uh my friend April
O'Neil's a Big Nerd and she's a she's a
porn star I can't think of like where
I'd put her though uh I think April
would be really fun as like
um I think she'd be a good mutant too
I'm kind of like stuck in that world
she'd be like a badass Cy Lodge in koi
fantasize on camera people I just trying
to think of like what April's Vibe is I
I just don't know how to porn stars I
don't think I think I'm I I don't know
if I can answer this honestly Asian
character that I don't know uh well yes
Alex definitely Asian and April's not
but I was just thinking of like her
energy April for Jubilee guy
I think there's just one Johnny Sins
everybody's saying like I don't really
know like I don't know I don't know his
work I don't know any names I don't know
if this is making us better or worse
like what does this say about us
I can think of like some influencer
chicks who I'm like are they adult actor
stars
um or are they like you know there's
like that weird ground now where it's
like they they just pretty much do
pornography but it's yeah but but it's
like only on only family I think like
sex workers because I think it's weird
that we have a girl I've seen Violet
something or another
um Hill no that's a song I forget her
name Violet Hills no I forget her name
um but someone who I've seen uh pop up I
don't know her name
um I thought I liked porn way more than
this I'm learning
a lot of data here but I don't I don't
know I don't know them for actor talents
yeah I can't say who would be good
definitely a different skill set a lot
of the time yeah but I do like this
question because sex work has worked I
completely uh agree that these people
don't know their names I think it's kind
of a shame that we can't even like we
probably demonetize the video just by
saying that I think I was careful about
the words I used as opposed to how I
used to be the fact that they were being
encouraging I'm saying that oh do you
think but it's the hour to that level
they do uh that's insane yeah I think
it's a real well this is a country
founded by prudes and we pretend it
isn't we still swear over a Bible this
country is so backwards and puritanical
yeah no I agree and I think it's a shame
because yeah I do believe that sex
worker sex work is okay it's the first
job it's the original job the first
thing we exchange
[Laughter]
or another name Violet something or
another
um I don't know Von Rouse
um hi Greg and koi off topic but I'm so
excited I live in North Carolina so I'm
pretty far I can't come see Greg Live
May 7th if I did buy it in pay-per-view
can't wait oh thank you so much totally
forgot to mention oh yeah you gotta
thank you the following week
um Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 uh
going to be doing a live show with John
Campion Christian
harloffers also Flappers we did one as 5
p.m Pacific Standard time we did one uh
for uh Ant-Man in the Lost Quantum
medium sold out so fast and it was one
of the best moments in my whole YouTube
career and getting to meet everyone as
well uh during and after the show I
would say and we want to do it again for
Guardians three and so now this time uh
similar to what koi has uh the week
before it was so McCoy has we're gonna
have a live It's Gonna Be Live uh in
person but we're also gonna have a
pay-per-view link so people like Vaughn
but someone did drive from like Ohio
that's incredible and they came up to me
and like I came here to see you I'm a
big fan of Kira Noir
that's someone I want Kiran noir's storm
should be excellent excellent being an
X-Men pun and a sex work pun
um say sorci Ronan should be the new I
think so she run it is a God damn she's
talented what's going on with her career
you're right Bradley thanks for bringing
her up Teague Coy are you excited for
the Venture Brothers move we did that
that's where I messed up my we went way
back dude I totally messed up we're
gonna skip the first 10 super chats hey
coyan Greg James Gunn uh this is from
ionicari thank you so much hey Coy and
Greg James Gunn was recently trolled for
promoting Guardians the Galaxy Vol 3.
even though he's heading DC Studios how
can people be so stupid
I
feel like people are seriously just
trolling I think James gun can sometimes
not see that these sometimes you don't
need to respond to everyone because I
think they're that irrational kind of
mindset
they're just uh their rational kind of
mindset to me is something where
they are just looking for something to
get mad about that they're not actually
upset about and I feel like James Gunn
should be able to just kind of ignore
that kind of side of the internet and
not feel like he has to respond unless
he was asked directly about it then he
has to answer like if he's doing an
interview you know sure but I believe it
was a tweet where he just replied to the
person about it because I don't think he
needs to answer that like it's so
obvious that he made this movie and I
believe the point that he brought up was
wouldn't DC want to work with a guy
who's going to follow through with the
work that he did prior to make sure to
promote that work that is still being
released even if it's from another
Studio I I think it's stupid that people
would think that what he's doing is
I mean like we need to stop this divide
between Marvel and DC to such that's the
first thing is there is no Marvel DC
Warner Brothers Disney rivalry beef uh
yeah Kevin I even made a video the day
they announced James gun then Kevin
feige and James got her friends he's the
first person James called was feige to
talk about and obviously him Shepard in
the universe James was there making the
the shared Universe out of Guardians
like he was part of that Brain Trust
he's learning those lessons I think it
benefits both of them for them both to
succeed and the average person that not
anybody in the Stream like not anybody
that's going to be so focused to the
nerd space to be in here a lot of people
I'd say upwards of 40 probably don't
know the difference between Marvel and
DC they just see a Superhero Movie so if
DC does poorly it affects on Marvel and
Marvel does perlite effects on DC so I
think Rising tide lifts all boats I
think this rivalry is bull I
think Jeff Johns and and Kevin feige
your friends and like they're at
different sides of things I also think
that James has been really smart about
he's running DC and warming it up while
he's got this Guardians press and it's
getting good press for both both
companies every time there's a lull in
news he can talk about the other one
which is only lifting things up so I
guarantee at the guardian's Press tour
there's going to be questions about DC
and I guarantee when he's starting up DC
there's going to be ramifications that
Guardians has so I think this is really
short-sighted and I I like Greg's
optimism that people aren't that stupid
I think some are uh so I think that
James has to probably see a thousand of
them and just answer one in order to get
people to stop maybe I know I just think
my there are some people who are that
dumb many at the same time
they should just be ignored not every
dumb person I think he probably got a
thousand went oh
yeah I think it was it was just a levy
broke and he just couldn't hang I do
want to talk about the Zack Snyder thing
at some point Alan Richton is I think
Alan Richton would be a great uh cyclops
oh that's interesting have you seen
Reacher I haven't is it good I saw you
to the first episode so I shot the
second one too I'm like he's
great yeah yeah I've heard he's like the
nicest guy like I've heard he looks like
that but then he's like intelligent
leader a giant dragon back to being
booked God damn we need the red Cyclops
uh Yuka Prieto Ryan Gosling ironically
it's my Cyclones
but you're limited from the thing he has
his biggest assets
you Yuca Prieta PJ Saturday stream bring
the nerdy onesies yeah now I got some
Star Wars ones coming these no joke like
I did an ad for me undies and like I'm
not promoting them in this they're not
in the description box or anything these
are feel this feel it oh that's nice
it's got this like typo is that like
Myla or something some type of I don't
know it's very soft but stretchy it's
like yes yes spandex cotton I'm even
wearing the underwear right now it is
very it's very it's amazing it's amazing
I uh I maybe maybe yeah I think that's
why we kept walking us around
uh but thank you Yucca haskell420 oh my
God I gotta show a photo then waiting
for someone to bring this up
Haskell 420 hey guys happy you met Keanu
Greg what did you ask him coin my
brother what's up well thank you Haskell
for uh for 20 for the shout out let's
let's find a photo let's keep this up
here for a bit while I pull most active
Tweeter in the game the scale's always
doing work because he's the man totally
forgot to hit uh the tweets here that
were live on all these things I prepped
in advance I just realized
um
no oh wait I'm on the Community page I
have it right oh right there yeah there
it is
yeah hold on oh I'm gonna pull it up on
frame don't you worry gang I got you
covered makes me so happy I just I'm
live streaming controlling literally the
image every time Greg's calls so let me
go left monitor large or move that oh my
God what's on screen right now no way of
doing oh oh there we go here's here's
here's what I'll do just so there it is
just so I don't mess up the dimensions
here no no I don't want to mess up the
dimension okay koi just chill I'll chill
my brethren
chill silence scares me
I know
all right oh I also figure that effect
slightest industry Oh yay yeah the chat
stays on screen
um yeah so
um uh basically I got coined to an event
where he could meet Keanu and I was like
you're welcome and I was like man I
really this is life change I know what
ended up happening was uh koi got an
invite to an event and then koi invited
me to join him and we didn't know I
didn't know what it was gonna be exactly
like
and then it ended up being a private
moment with Keanu one on well like as
you can see here can I set up the
context of right before this though
really quick I just want to mention yeah
actually yeah yeah you do it because the
story is a fun Journey so the day or two
days before Greg was asking me about my
schedule because I was like uh we're
trying to figure out uh recording I
think uh oh DC thing yeah and he was
like hey what's your availability on
blah blah blah day and I was like oh I'm
free after one by the way that morning
do you want to come meet Keanu Reeves
and like it was so great to be like sin
yeah and like Greg like didn't know how
to respond to that he kept being like
typing because I think you thought I was
with you so I love that I was
just like hey by the way you're sure
you're free well the I was like I have
to pull I'm gonna be up late for
Mandalorian because it was the finale
and then of course that was the night
where our video just kept getting
blocked and I didn't get it up till 7 30
in the morning so I was like not
sleeping
right now and um and yeah
um so you see here this is this is the
moment
let me move the chat here for a tiny bit
so you guys can see
and the this is this is the moment when
I was starting to talk to him and he put
his his hand up to his his close fist up
to his chin was really listening where I
was like now I don't know what I'm
saying because I'm hyper aware he
already just paying attention to me can
I say that was that no one I think I've
ever met in my life in the millions of
people I've met listens like Keanu
Reeves he was like super engaged and
what I brought up to because he was
there to promote his comic book uh
Berserker which looks great and
um as you can see here he actually
signed one for me it's all and he he
dedicated it because I mentioned I was a
writer my passions in writing and he put
made them made the Muse be with you dude
I love that he was like trying to think
of something and he was like do I put it
it's like oh like well what do you do
that's what he says like what do you do
he's like I was like I run a YouTube
channel and I I love to raise like
made the Muse be with you and then I was
like yeah it's perfect he's like
and he's just like smiled and didn't
want to do it and and what I basically
talked to him about and I and I feel
like this did not come out
um eloquently at all when talking with
Keanu Reeves I really don't think this
came out eloquently was that
oh let me fix this really quick
let me fix it
this just looks like so chaotic
yes so I'm going to move the chat here
for a tiny bit uh just for a tiny bit
just so it's clear uh so what what I was
trying to say was something that I that
I was because I wanted to say something
genuine because I was like obviously I
haven't read I hadn't read the comic yet
koi has raved about this comic to me
countless times and a lot of comments I
read are based off Coy's recommendations
but I hadn't read the comic yet and I
didn't want to like Keanu
Reeves so but I would love it the truth
well I love it what I really loved was
like I saw John Wick three times and um
I don't really go to the theaters that
often which is true because I usually
wait to react to them now here in the
channel and one thing that I really love
that I think is underrated about Keanu
Reeves's performance is what I really
wanted to say something I don't feel
like it's enough commentary is that his
his his performance and his body
language during the action scenes has
such a performance in and of itself it's
not just choreography it's not just
fight like a lot of that's that was kind
of the Divide for me when it came to him
and Halle Berry in the third John Wick
movie 100 was there's eight like she's
got the choreography down but there is
such an emotive performance there where
you can see the pain and anguish and the
struggle the intensity and that's what
makes it believable despite how
ridiculous the physics are what gets you
invested in the stakes is Keanu Reeves's
performance with the intensity and the
struggle that he puts for it take Mom
work and it is such good minding and he
was talking to me about and then he
started talking he started like
monologuing about how the grief shines
through during those action scenes and
that's what he's like really channeling
and I mentioned the thing of how it was
like some people compare to Fast and
Furious and he's like well no and I cut
him off because I was like no that's the
thing is that because of your
performance it makes it believable and
the stakes feel real and so I I wanted
to say something eloquent like that did
not I I I know the second the second he
did this I was like nope don't know what
I'm saying anymore
I I'm hyper I've just become aware I'm
looking at Kiana the first thing that
happened was I walked into him awkwardly
and I was like
hi I'm Greg he's like hey pause he went
hi I'm Keanu and then he shook my hand
man so yeah and I mentioned I wanted to
do more comedies too because uh yeah so
yeah but no it's the mat the biggest
thanks really goes to koi on that uh
like I'm very grateful because I would
not have had this both Kevin feige
and Keanu Reeves I met via through koi
only reason I keep this guy around me
meet people you love meet famous people
this is why I keep him around I uh I
want to share that the moment uh we
walked in or I I was I had already
talked to him and there was like a a
circle of like hang after but the moment
we walked in and I saw Greg's face was
just joy and like when I think of that
day and I tweeted this and I mean it
from the bottom of my heart when I think
of that day it's like the fifth thing I
think of is my conversation with Keanu
because all of the Greg moments for
highlights in my brain yeah to see Greg
glowing walking in and then to hear like
his sheer exuberance walking up to meet
him and then like to see that photo
later literally every time Greg calls me
now I'm so happy because it's just you
glowing next to Keanu I think that is a
perfect profile picture I love it so
much and Keanu uh is everything you've
heard and uh we talked I said that's one
of the things I said to him was like you
were just you were I said that like when
he was times like you were exactly like
what everyone is you were Alliance I
just had to say it I finally got to ask
him something that's been driving me
insane uh because I I wasn't able to
talk about it on the panel because we
just had only so many things we could
had allotments for because we announced
in anime we announced a live action we
announced a movie uh sorry a
novelization
um but I've always loved that Berserker
is an immortal struggling with
immortality so I asked Keanu whether
writing this was a meditation on
mortality and with John Wick being a
meditation on violence through peace oh
sorry on peace through violence this
felt like a meditation on mortality
through immortality and whether or not
he felt that when he finished this first
Arc whether he felt any sense of closure
and he like paused and was really
thoughtful and he's like I think the
thing about mortality is it's a constant
acceptance and then I said is your work
with Ron Garney who's a martial artist
the artist on the book is a martial
artist as well and they both are martial
artists and that's something they bond
over like me Ron and Keanu have talked
about the importance of the physicality
of martial arts in the character a lot
so I asked him as a follow-up the the
Flow State you get in working on martial
arts does that also come into play when
you're writing and then he gave me this
beautiful eloquent very Keanu response
about basically the flow state is when
he knows he's alive because he's not
thinking about mortality and then coming
back to reality when he knows he's left
flow is that mortality coming back in
and he tries to incorporate that in all
of his work and he tries to make sure
that sense of flow is why he does what
he loves and that's when he knows he
loves something so we got into the great
conversation about like flow and love
and life and martial arts and writing
and movies and it was just like I want
this to be the next six hours of my life
like I'm talking to this man who's so
interesting and eloquent and poignant
but he's also he looks into your soul in
such a beautiful way that you know he's
listening because he wants to give a
response that is an actual response he's
the least sound bite person I've ever
met he just he he's with you on this
journey and then at the end of the day
we announced uh or they announced the
next day at IGN but we talked about it
there that Steve scross is doing
the one shot and that they might not
register to as many people as comic fans
but Steve's gross one of the best
artists out there his X-Men his
Spider-Man like a lot of these iconic
things but the reason this is exciting
specifically to Keanu is keanu's
co-writing this one shot or it's his
character Steve scross is writing and
drawing a Keanu Reeves one shot Steve
Gross did the previous on The Matrix so
Steve's gross was the guy that
storyboarded with the wachowskis and now
he's doing art for Keanu 25 years later
so I got to talk to Keanu about uh
basically pre-vising with the machowskis
and he's the humblest man so basically
he was like you know like Steve and the
machowskis would just talk and I'd show
up and not just do the acting but I was
like no no so we got to talk about
previzing the Matrix and like I was
losing my mind because like Greg knows
that's my religion like the Matrix so to
hear Keanu talk about Steve's gross in
relation to comics and one of my
favorite movies uh I I also had quite
the day it was really beautiful
I love that man
you know I just realized they can see
what I'm typing they can yeah that's
right there those are your hands so I'm
just going to be like
hurry the up
telling things about
you I'll just mess around one of the
great honors of my life was making that
happen that was that was his
absolute joy and I I forever be grateful
and you've solidified your spot here at
the real region that's how I earned it
not the hours of content and labor it is
that not the actual all right Kevin
it's been two years since he met Keanu
can you come in
um here we go here we go
um but thank you again koi Brandon
tonberry thank you Brandon I'm okay with
Adam Driver but I love Jody comer or
Vanessa Kirby at Sue what do you guys
think I do think Vanessa Kirby would be
a fascinating pick I think she's another
very underrated actor she's proven
herself in the action genre as well but
she does more like what I love about
when I think about something like
Vanessa Kirby he's like I'm introduced
to her via an action film first which is
Hobbs and Shaw
and before I or other Hobson Shaw or or
the mission impossible I don't know
which one came first
um but then you find other words she did
and then what I love about the action
genre now is that there's not really an
action star anymore yeah that a lot of
them are first actors who did
yeah and Vanessa Kirby is one of those
actors who I met via the action genre
and then now
um I think she would be a great Sue
storm
you know what
nah I still think Jody Comer is a better
better pick I don't even covers my neck
actually I just rap I do yeah and
Vanessa Kirby I would not be like oh no
it's not Jody Comer but I think if I
like infinite pick Jody Comer Joe Kolby
says uh I saw Vanessa Kirby is in Emma
Frost definitely armor Frost there's
been a lot of uh love for for Jenna
Frost lately I wonder if Jenna Ortega
would join the Marvel Cinematic Universe
hold on gang I'm just gonna refresh this
really quick and I'm gonna check General
Ortega is my um Zatanna and check the
stream Labs super fast those ended
armists though those two
boom boom reset this hold on everyone
here we go Greg's gonna just fix a
couple of things here
that stuff I did hear that Michael Sarah
confirmed Superman what's happening
there's that there's that disgusting
film account yeah I love that guy
because he just constantly gets people
guys just reach read the and you'll
know buffing do you see a thing here
there it is I found it I was just trying
to like be like bam there it is oh
I the ride
things have gone awry the wrong one no
Greg Greg get your crap in order and
Greg thinks I'm gonna run this and talk
he's chaotic with two of us all right
hold I'm just gonna refresh some things
because I know we're we're behind we've
gone on a couple of tangents here the
thing I usually yell at you and John
about I have massively contributed you
got to make Keanu Reeves sometimes you
gotta tan sometimes we we gotta talk
about Kiana for a very long I mean it's
it's we're only in like an hour 10
minutes from great
one would think okay we've got a couple
of uh stream Labs here that I do want to
make sure we get to as well
I think it's streamlabs that helps out
very much appreciate it I've traveled
with Nick Hill will always get to all
the super chats always
watch
and learn
how Greg does everything
just going to control Z this journey
back to success
help I got this under control
very good aha
oh you can actually see the streamlabs
we've never been able to see them ice
cream
yeah MJ Doris thank you for the stream
labs they take less of a fee which is
like 10 versus YouTube's 50 so thank you
MJ doors hey guys love the streams if
they ever adapted mistborn storm life
books into TV or movies would you
consider covering them the
interconnected Universe fits right into
your other interest you know I have a
lot to say on it but I'm gonna be
generous here here and uh take it away
cool there's you know like I feel like
you have to really earn your way to
eventually doing a solo stream here and
while I can handle this you got to prove
this obviously yes
uh I think the mistborn and Stormlight
books are very very very beloved and I
don't like talking about things uh as a
as a casual fan I think that's why I
don't cover anime that's why I don't
cover video games is I don't know them I
like I'm aware of them these are that uh
I think I look at a lot of comic book
hosts that are really just
Wikipedia hosts people read log lines I
read the comic and it really is
insulting actually read the oh I
would leave this to the actual Die Hard
fans that have earned it I would rather
people cover it that are worthy than me
I I don't know that world that well and
I do think that it's a market but it's a
lot like covering uh anything halfway
you could watch an expert or you could
waste time watching a novice and I don't
think that it's a world that I could
dive into enough to make it worth your
time for me to cover personally well
damn I just want to be honest looks like
we're not covering Kung Fu Panda
together oh no that's I'm an expert in I
know I know
foreign
that's your announcement folks we're
gonna be doing Kung Fu Panda watch
alongs Mr Eli Mack thank you so much for
the stream Labs hey first stream Labs oh
you're seeing Rogue you'll have your sim
card as our Friday congratulations we
see it Thursday yeah so excited
um I could look here I keep forgetting
that uh Hey first stream live stream I
was curious in your thoughts of this fan
casting Nick Robinson as Superman I
think he'd be an interesting Superman
and he's around the same age you're
looking for also he'd be a unique choice
in my opinion do you remember Nick
Robinson from um the uh Simon well I was
thinking the the World movie uh we're
using the woods um those are boys at
summer or something I named two movies
and you're focused on one because the
one I have is very Superman it's very
Kansas he's great uh I think he was also
in mud anyway uh fantastic young actor
great resume uh recognizable but not a
household name which I think is what
they want for Superman I don't know how
big he currently is and if he'd have
time to gain the mass you'd want for
Superman he is very Clark Kent and he's
very
um Kansas but boots got to be yoked like
you guys got it big so if Nick Robertson
is currently jacked I'm all for that
and tur isn't here I would make a great
Jimmy Olsen and James Olson from the
Supergirl show said as much when we did
an interview we talked about art
differences Jimmy versus James Olson and
it was very funny I think that Nick see
the problem with Superman is I feel like
the casting for him
I'm waiting for them to get bold with
casting Superman it's Sterling it's a
very like obvious kind of casting you
gotta do for Superman it's always the
same look you need that guy it's the
same like they all have this similar
look they do at the end of the day they
all do Brandon Routh Christopher Reeves
Henry Cavill it's just find the find the
eyes and the hair and the whiteness and
then uh bulk up right I'm not saying you
guys of course yeah I know I'm just
saying like the the look is always the
same and I don't know what I want though
I'm also complaining about something
that I don't know what I want for her
there I am I'm part of the internet like
I don't really know what I want uh
because I would I feel like with James
Gunn I know you gotta played a little
bit safe on your first go around but
also with Superman and it's Superman
especially now with the backlash like
you do got to play it safe but one thing
I love about James gone is he tends to
cast in a way you wouldn't expect you
know even Chris Pratt is Star-Lord it
was a weird pick and like just enough
weird like fits but just enough strange
you know what I mean where because like
Star-Lord is a little bit more like he
could do the whole thing but there's a
reason Zach Levi went out guardian's
game is more Star-Lord look yeah you
know versus like what I saw as uh
oh Chris Pratt right but I don't
know what the unique one David dust
mulchin a star it says Superman
confirmed get it going
weirdest pick you could do in the world
he's great uh also I I just thought
wrestling live chat I don't know who it
was because you don't matter your name
uh someone asked if I just like this out
of my own voice why I talk so much I
actually hate the sound of my voice but
I don't have sentences that like are
linear so I have to talk a lot to get my
point I already acknowledged it for you
oh did you I already said we he does
love the sound of his own voice I listen
to it to go to sleep I record myself
telling myself a lullaby I'm refreshing
everything's gonna come back okay
ready
I was just trying to Vamp for you and
now I got shut down they should get
Batman to be played by a little man that
would be awesome
oh look at like a pure Dinklage yeah all
right
then no one would ever know who Batman
was it'd be so serious
sense
that's why no one can put it together
that's why I can't have a beard because
you'd know but if he doesn't have a
beard ever clean shaven little person
put two and two together would watch
um you know some people are like that's
offensive but it's also hilarious oh
yeah no we've been canceled no let it
happen
pulling it all back oh damn
hold on guys the dimension come on you
know this is better for playback this
look right right yeah you know it is
choose fourth squeeze I would like to
watch this while we're like flailing
around on screen in between sections I
mean I was looking into this idea last
night with John to figure it out because
I've I watched your guys's stream back
and I'm like there's gotta be a way to
make this look better on playback
yeah I feel like this is a good Dynamic
I want to get to that hundred dollar
Super Chat oh yeah hold on guys okay
monitor monitor okay this was the last
one we left off on yeah okay was that it
for sure I'm positive koi I pay
attention to things sure unlike you who
just listens to the sound of his own
voice it's actually my voice in the
headphones oh
ah
this is actually me and John's live
stream I'm listening to but I have it so
it's just me
oh no I messed it all up
call John John we need you go Sean I
messed it up everyone
I've done I've done a duty okay hold on
I got this guys I got this oh yeah I
could just control Z this everyone calm
down
everyone calm down I'm determined to fix
this
go and be quiet I'm just vibing Greg's
trying his best here to keep your stream
good yeah
he's acknowledged that it's just my own
voice playing the headphones for him too
read read people's comments in the chat
while I'm doing anything for the
Nintendo cinematic universities I would
love to see more from that world of
Mario I think it's a spectacular world I
enjoyed the World building the movie was
very linear but that's a great start for
a universe uh to answer koi's question
it's pretty entertaining I'm not sure
what's entertaining but I appreciate
that uh John Humphrey is Superman
perfect casting Choice John Humphrey
confirmed Superman uh can you imagine
getting an action figure something flash
I wonder how many people are gonna buy I
think that movie's gonna do very well uh
koi what MCU Multiverse characters would
you match up in a fight uh I don't know
if that's was that the question uh what
do you manager up in a battle world
fight oh I love that question battle
world is the world that's kind of like
the Crux of Secret Wars It's like a
tapestry of of universes and worlds that
allows for that to exist uh I would love
to see
Hulk fight Thor again but with like this
this new Hulk uh I would actually know
what I want to see She-Hulk fight Thor
that'd be fun uh because we've seen Hulk
fight Thor uh I would love to see
um Spider-Man and Star-Lord fighting
because I feel like Star-Lord got a lot
of craftiness and like Spidey wouldn't
want to hurt him uh I would want to see
ooh Captain Marvel and who's who else is
like cartoonishly powered that we don't
see fight a lot who do you fight Captain
Marvel with uh definitely pay attention
to everything okay and I'm ready to move
on now okay I think you covered it all
going off I like Kobe feet I like Kunis
I like Kunis but I think she would be an
awful choice for Sue she just doesn't
have a commanding presence that Sue Has
Jupiter Ascending Oz and Max Payne I
want someone like Betty Gilpin for Sue
man I feel like she'd be
a stick pick black you can name bad like
like those are bad he does have a
Cadence in her that is a very specific
kind of cadence it's structured I don't
want her I want her to have an
opportunity to really showcase that I
feel like Black Swan showed just how
much of a force she can be with the
right team and the right director but
even there she was still like you know
the fun sexual girl and and like while
she's done other works outside of it but
in terms of like looking at her biggest
stuff you know like it's you usually is
like comedies or something like that you
know like I love her and like Forgetting
Sarah Marshall I I love them the
benefits I thought she was excellent in
that yeah but this would be an
opportunity because Sue Storm's a Smart
Cookie yeah I think Mila Kunis I
personally think should be a great
superstorm uh but I I want to see her
get to flex those different muscles too
sure
yeah now I'm John sure sure
all right we're moving on here we go the
ultimate one look at that massive Super
Power King Lucifer we are now Satan is
here at the real region
all it takes we are we are greedy we
have we have been bought by 100 to
conform
to an evil religion here but do we say
evil now that we're satanists together I
think Catholics people are uh misjudging
Satan in this that's what I gotta say I
agree I think Satan Lincoln's get a bad
rap sadness uh have done a lot for the
community and they control the
government so so exactly sadness you
hate America is what I'm getting at
people
what is insanity to me just like that is
that that doesn't make us look boss you
look Boss by doing yeah appreciate you
Sasha Barn Cohen as Lucifer slash
Mephisto that's wild your soul belongs
to me exactly Blue Lemon peats lemon on
Pizza
um okay here we go we're back to the uh
we're back to hold on a second
God damn it correct get your
together
keep it together
you've seen a
uh Bowfinger oh wow years ago yeah I was
like what was that from I know that keep
it together
um for me I just want to see what
they'll do with lanterns and what's your
cast fix for both Hal Jordan and Jon
Stewart well I think for Hal Jordan you
should get Hal Rudnick and then for Jon
Stewart
yeah it shows Jon Stewart the name's
already on the trailer I think it will
be a very interesting pick uh for Hal
Jordan that's where I think that's where
I feel okay I feel like James Gunn will
play it safe
you're like I'm gonna go I feel like
James gun will could play it safe for
superman but he should go a little bit
against type for
um
for when it comes to like Hal Jordan and
Jon Stewart
I feel like he'll go against type with
his obscure characters but I feel like
there are certain archetypal ones I
still think oh man Glenn Powell I don't
think he's booster I think he's Hal man
I think honestly it's right there don't
do it it's right there that's what I
want man that's what I want don't do it
man Washington John David Washington man
John David Washington I mean it's a
weird thing it is kind of a strange
thing isn't it when you like you want
them to go against type and usually
people imply race right so if you go
like you take a white guy and you make
him like a black guy or an Asian or a
Latino doesn't matter right whatever
something that's not white you're like
okay make it a choice but then if the
character from the comic is Black you
don't want to change that right isn't
that isn't that thing do it it's like
it's you under you kind of get it it's a
bit strange but not strange when you
think about why it's not strange it's a
volume thing like there was like 40
years of just like characters in it it
is it is a fascinating because you're
like you really want to keep it on super
black though if you look at like the
entire Silver age it's like what guy
maybe a woman crazy I'm so like yeah you
don't want to change the tiny amount of
characters that are authentically that
race well the sad part is is that
weirdly Ryan Reynolds should have worked
yeah like he really should have worked
as as Hal Jordan he was uh that type of
Ryan Reynolds is perfect there's not a
lot of White characters that are like I
have to be white because it's my
character's identity but since they
weren't writing a lot of black
characters a lot of the black characters
that is part of her character so I don't
think you can change black characters
because it's like part of their Journey
which is why when everybody's like oh
you want to make blah blah blah what
about black panther white like it's just
them being dumbasses okay well we got
John boyega's getting a lot of love in
the chat for Jon Stewart Anthony Starr
Jordan be fun uh from Lethal Weapon and
a lot of like indie films
um Glenn Powell's torch is fun but yeah
I think that those are going to be I
personally think they're gonna lean
pretty straightforward at the uh the
Green Lanterns true
well thank you for the Super Chat Aisha
Kenya uh sorry I'm scrolling too fast
Aisha Kenya thank you so much for being
back here my dear you're oh is there a
lot of Thrones
happy Saturday build your own sup
Voltron suit Powers Baxter and weapons
what's which superheroes would you pick
so like five to form Voltron is that the
question yeah I think kind of like a
Power Ranger okay so let's make a super
team
oh to like build into one big super into
Voltron right yeah okay well I think
what's important is you need like a a
flight okay you always need a flight yep
um so which superhero would you pick for
that for flight storm storm for flight
yeah she's like she controls the winds
she also can like manipulate all the
things around her she can float and fly
and she can do stuff while she's doing
it and then also
um what is okay and then the other one
you need I think you need some type of
like manipulation of Weaponry okay Green
Lantern
uh I mean I think Wally West flash I
think why specifically Wally West
comedic more fun yeah we want our
Voltron machine from the hybrid I want
them to enjoy your trap you're trapped
together you want something to make it
levity super intelligence underrated
when thinking about your uh hyper weapon
thing but you want someone to steer and
Lead leadership as well uh Lex Luthor
obviously obviously hyper intelligence
leadership uh I'm gonna go Xavier
because he could actually get in the
minds people to make it sync up faster
right okay that's good that's four and
then um just to you get a a one up here
what about uh okay you already got the
mind reader down we got 30 seconds
coming with another one it's another
typical power Set uh guys help us out
here Jesus Christ like what other like
types of power let's move on to the the
power let's move I don't know where
we're going with five uh let's go to The
Back Store here oh wow we're just still
there yeah uh a bunch of people uh from
the Multiverse are all trapped in battle
world because of Secret Wars but it's
also part of the amalgam universe so
when battle world in the amalgam
Universe combined you're allowed to
bring Marvel and DC together but since
it's a collapsing Universe you have to
form Voltron in order to keep the
different environments at Bay so just in
case they have a suit they have to be in
in order to have the environments
approachables they can think through
through it so they form Voltron in order
to regulate the universe and go around
solving problems and having to battle to
settle the the collapse of their two
universes together
and that's why koi's gonna get a solo
show here
the time Straight No Strings I do like
strength kind of comes into play here
they're all strong
thank you guys I don't even know how
many people are in the Stream anymore if
you guys are here leave a like everyone
leave a like if you haven't done so
already
and if you have log into a new account
leave a like okay
here we go
homecoming one just putting this out
there
thank you for the Super Chat there's a
guy who often shops the store a workout
he looks like koi in about 15 years
thanks homecoming one Corey does have a
unique look dad uh he's got a very Irish
look yeah I I look I think is it Bill
Burr because I just I'm gonna look like
Bill Burton 15. if you had an Irish
accent dude I would fit like you look
like you would have an Irish accent
losing the Boston accent was hard
because I've had the mustache twirl yeah
it was fun but I looked like a cartoon I
look more like a cliche than I do can
you grow the the no it doesn't connect I
can't I take uh acne medicine as a kid
and it like scar it like Napalm with my
pores so I like this isn't a style
Choice it's just what I'm allowed
because you know how sometimes you get
like these problems with gigs where
they're like you're too white so we
can't have you uh oh at Orange I feel
yeah I I was thinking about I was like
maybe if you had like more facial hair
here
that's what I noticed the whities who
get the gigs dude
that beard up yeah because for some
reason it kind of hides the whities
what kind of work you just look like the
guy from Game of Thrones there's not a
lot of Gingers in the game they just
don't we don't they don't let my people
in uh yeah so I'm wondering who this guy
is you get his name you let me know
Google and see if there's a company or
an insult what's going on with
Spider-Man start on Disney plus uh the
rights were bought years ago and I think
they would like waiting for a certain
licensing time from release of no way
home to have them all on there bam
figure it out Raul Gorman Brian Gorman
ideal Doom opposite of driver Ah that's
a great way to phrase that question
actually uh thank you for the Super Chat
Killian has always been my main choice
and I think he'd play off each other
well Cavill could work too oh it's
interesting to think of it in the
context of if you have Adam Driver and
who would be a great one to play off of
Adam Driver but what and I think you
could kind of imagine what an Adam
Driver Reed Richards would sort of be
like
Ian McDermott
I still like Rufus soul I see rufusul
opposite I'd rather pretty clean Mark
Hamill going on as blocker from
Jane's hot Lobster back uh okay Doom
opposite I like Killian Murphy I just
think he's a little uh he's a short man
and I feel like Adam driver's a big man
and I just don't know if that visual I
know you can make him look tall like Tom
Hardy's my height but like
I feel like killing just feels a smaller
guy
um I think of like who was like an
intimidating guy that maybe I saw on a
television show who's not that known
mm-hmm
um but is also scary
I really want to get this down I think
Jonathan Tucker would be a fun Jonathan
Tucker love Johnson Tucker I think and
he's intimidating he's got a presence
he's really intense be a fun one who's
Jonathan Tucker uh dude from Kingdom is
from uh
well he's on a lot of things a lot of
people don't know uh like he's a great
TV actor he was on Kingdom he was on a
bunch of NBC NBC shows last year what
movies is he like do you like Joel
edgers I like this thing he's a gentle
energy
he's got like this even in the gift he's
got a general what about Jason Bateman
oh that's the move just slow comedic I
am do
it's just sarcastic yeah see all of his
lines are like they're not metallics
they're just in sass uh I mean I do
think the the obvious choices would
would work like you said
um homeboy from Casino Royale uh mads
Mickelson yeah
um I I really like Rufus who is stuck
mine because he's got this nightliness
that I think Doom needs I think Doom
should be like what a night is an evil
he has the look yeah and he's got the
voice and he's got like I don't trust
him but I'm also Enchanted by his like
what's he's gonna do yeah yeah he's
definitely got the look someone in that
energy do you guys know who Rufus soul
is
here I'll show you guys who koi's
picking
and then look up Jonathan Tucker for you
so you know Rufus Sewell one of my
favorite actors yeah rufusul okay I'm
gonna remove this there he is there he
is I mean that guy looks like Doom
remove this from the chat for just a
tiny bit here he's been my pick since
like O2
hold on a sec sorry okay we're gone
through this out okay we're just I'm
just gonna share my screen basically
there we go
uh huh uh-huh and then let's do that
it's not doing it not doing it it's not
doing the thing I wanted to do everyone
Google Google
look up Jonathan Tucker you might know
him yeah okay I'll look up Jonathan
Tucker hold on because I think this guy
needs to be in Marvel oh wait a minute I
don't think I know what went wrong here
oh okay hold on let me just fix this
no do the thing that I want you to do
Nobody Got Time stupid screen stupid
hold on oh wait a minute I got one way
of doing that also all this is happening
fun fact Rufus Sewell and Heath Ledger
are almost single-handedly responsible
for the David Bowie inclusion in A
Knight's Tale they uh fought for it and
helped pay for it
this is Jonathan Tucker who I think is
like one of the most underrated actors
working uh I would I want him and look
at that last photo that's at Dr Dumas
photo yeah uh I this is my guy oh yes
he's in Westworld yeah he's incredible
man yeah yeah I remember huge tuck fan
um and then Rufus Sewell Rufus Sewell as
your pick for yeah these are my two guys
yeah yeah it looks like a guy that runs
like that very like he's got an energy
to him he does this is a really
interesting visual on screen right now
and he also hasn't done anything of this
scale like he's not been yeah I feel
like Clive Owen took his spot like and I
was like come on let rufusul play it'd
be cool to see Henry Cavill back in I
agree I agree guys uh also Colin Collins
uh tuck does look enough like me that um
I've actually like my whole life got in
that because he grew up 20 minutes for
me oh really Tucker literally like
neighbors and uh we have mutual friends
and uh you get that a lot he's got my
energy I like him he's manic
all right here we are here we are
any Jedi Survivor predictions
I feel like crashing coyote thank you
release this Friday oh my God I don't
really have any predictions it releases
Friday
I don't know what this question means oh
there's a video game called Jedi Fallen
order which stars cameras yeah
Billboards okay and then there's uh Jedi
Survivor which is the follow-up and I I
wanted to replay Jedi Fallen order I was
thinking of figuring today is how to I
know it was a massive just like pile on
the work
um I wanted to I wanted to uh I was
thinking of Michael Tessler and I who
did Mandalorian with uh I was thinking
of trying to uh figure out how to stream
play with you guys I've never done that
here and I thought that would be fun
because I really did enjoy the
experience of playing the first one
elements
I normally Reserve gaming for myself as
like my own personal Hobby and then once
in a while talk about something here
because we could do like comic video
games like give like wrecks and play I
don't want to turn my main hobby into a
slime with me I was like you can't sure
you I mean that's not my name games uh
I'm good at Comic games because I can
learn like Injustice like that kind of
fun I mean I've never yeah and uh but I
I wanted I wanna I'm thinking of figured
out how to play Jedi Survivor here on on
the channel and I'm just waiting for to
me it's odd that that there's been
nothing about Cameron Monahan coming
into the live action when it's insane
you made him look exactly like
an actor it's not like she's not good on
camera like make it happen you got Ahmed
best to come back which is great but uh
yeah like get okay Cameron man Cameron
Monahan in there it's something that
everyone wants it'd be such an easy way
for Kathleen Kennedy to make some people
happy he was a celebration not that
they're gonna announce it like he when
he came out on the stage I was like
uh I would love to do that oh yeah that
would be amazing uh travel with Nick
nikhil Russian I'm wondering if Dr
Manhattan could not erase Superman from
existence in Doomsday Clock number 12.
how dceu would erase him and replace
with Supergirl
fascinating question thanks for the
Super Chat Coy do you know what the hell
already he's talking about yeah so in
Doomsday Clock number 12 they combine
the worlds of which I didn't agree with
uh Watchmen into the DC Universe yeah
and it well I mean it was fine but like
Watchmen to me it's a vertigo comic yes
it's DC but it didn't work because the
commentary on a world shouldn't then go
into the world I think the authority is
an exception because it's going to be a
commentary in real time on our culture
as well like the boys is whereas like
Watchmen is about
um the arrogance of Heroes it's about
the arrogance of believing in Heroes
it's about what our world is as a we've
failed in this system so if you have the
failure of the system in the system it
doesn't quite work
um so having Dr Manhattan and Superman
meet it inherently didn't really like
land and so when like you know Rorschach
and Batman meet that's that's it's a
cool image but it doesn't really work
narratively so I think that honestly
they should never touch uh Watchmen in
the DC EU but like I think James Gunn is
going to be respectable about this yeah
100 yeah and I think the Watchman show I
didn't want and then it was perfect so
I'm just afraid of them double dipping
and like going awry
sure Jay Colby P back at it let me
adjust the live thing for the visual
imagery because I know you guys are
super invested in this just as much as
me right now so invested
hold your breath everyone
thank you Kobe I think you travel with
nikki'll appreciate you doing that for
Ben leave Schreiber or Mark Wahlberg as
both show to play tough characters but
they can bring out a vulnerable side in
each other's Spotlight for leave the
fighter and Invincible for Wahlberg what
are we talking about again is this in
reference to your earlier maybe the
thing because I I think either of them
could play the thing is this a oh it
might have been for
um it might be the thing or it might be
for it's someone in the Fantastic Four
that's for sure I think I'm assuming
doctor do maybe
I think leave stride would be a very
fascinating pick for Doom for Doom I
like to be a very fascinating Pig and
Redemption for saber tooth oh God yes
yeah actually I I would be that that
would not be everyone's top pick but I
think he would deliver I agree I'd love
to see that interesting yeah I wouldn't
have thought of that
no Mark Wahlberg for Doom please God but
for the love of God watch father stew
guy available on Netflix just watch
everything Mark Wahlberg just not Hennis
too Levi for a thing over Mark I think
Mark Wahlberg would be a funny thing
a funny like buddy he's from Boston said
New York um who cares no but like I'm
gonna do it but he doesn't have a Boston
accent oh Maki Mack totally does
sometimes he puts it on that's true like
athletic when that dunk said but no I
think I think Mark Wahlberg would be a
fun the way how
I mean it's not exactly Akin but you got
like Bradley Cooper for Rocket you got
Vin Diesel for Groot yeah oh he said for
Ben someone just yeah thank you Ryan
it's at least the first you were right
there on the screen what is this yeah oh
yeah and I was thinking Mark Wahlberg
would be a funny ver like that would be
interesting I think he would be an
interesting tool and Mark well and then
the thing you know you he's not just a
comedic character but there's a lot of
Comedy that can be associated with thing
yeah and I think Mark Wahlberg is
actually an excellent comedic actor oh
100 his stuff with Will Ferrell is
genius and Ted uh yeah they're I mean
these are both Boston boys so I want
them like live and Ben and Mark are both
from Boston so I support that but uh I
almost see a lot of more as Doom but I
think he'd be a live could also be a
great thing these are fun I like these
in the chat Aaron knight uh I do love
your pick for Lois Kat Dennings oh
I got a soft spot for Kat Dennings does
it become a hard spot no because you're
married you can't can't find anyone
attractive that's the rule that's what
you give away is finding anyone attract
horse blinders give it all away yep
healthy it's the key to marriage you
shut it down and then you you join the
elite rich and you do things in private
carries a taser hotels that's how you do
it Brandy Torres thank you Brandi well
there are be more spots top tier of
patreon
what do you mean by that I'm trying my
best here to run everything in order uh
oh do you mean like uh oh for shout outs
uh I I think so
I appreciate you being here shouts out
to Brandi Torres for being here nfx
visuals uh thank you so much have you
all seen beef on Netflix I am dying to
see this show I've heard only the best
fighters I've had no time but I heard
it's incredible
um apparently it doesn't look like it's
doing that well on YouTube and sometimes
you gotta factor that in if you're gonna
commit like
hours per episode to something and uh
and and so I was looking through
analytics and checking Googling stuff
I'm like okay apparently I'm like on
this platform no one wasn't doing that
well
um so the interest doesn't look super
high for it but I do want to watch it
but right now I'm there's a lot I'm
wrapping up and a lot I'm working on and
then I'm also trying to for the ultimate
experience and review experience for
Guardians 3 trying to get in all the
re-watches as well on my own times that
way I can really because I feel like
I feel like some of the Marvel sequels
you can just you know just go with not
this yeah but but for Guardians I'm like
it seems like he's selling a whole tale
and I need it fresh in my head so that
way I can see I don't think I've seen
Guardians 2 since theaters because I saw
it three times in theaters it's been
like five years so yeah I never watched
those yeah so I I would definitely watch
this and by the way guys I was telling
koi before the Stream
this is kind of crazy I did not think
this opinion would happen as I have said
this that I'm not a big fan of Guardians
too in fact it was one of the ones I was
saying I don't like
and I hadn't seen it I saw it a couple
months before infinity war came out
and I feel like I was a very I feel like
every two to three years I'm like a
different person like in my personal
life I feel like I'm a very different
person every two to three years and
maybe I've just grown a lot or been
through their experiences or something
or just whatever like it's part of the
beautiful things about a subjective
experience in movies and I re-watch
Guardians too
and I was shocked to see be like
I love this movie it's so good so it's
great I've never understood amazing the
hate I saw it three times in theaters
because I kept being like am I wrong I
saw it in the theaters I didn't like it
I really didn't like it it was kind of
okay to me this on my re-watch but then
but then for some reason like I watched
Guardians one and then I watched it
again and maybe and I might maybe it has
something to do with knowing what the
what happens after two so kind of seeing
like the bigger picture
but um yeah I love that story I think
it's like a perfect follow-up and as
someone who loves Iron Man 3. it's
really hard when you're like what am I
seeing differently and Guardians 2 has
been like that for me for a while I I
mean I I do have some objections still
about how Drax has evolved into just
like idiot but uh
and idiot and just hyper mean like yeah
like he's just nasty right
um but yeah but yeah I do think it and
that's true hellaby we are different
people every day with our every seven
years I think every single piece of us
has changed so yeah
um Jake Colby BP
um anyway nfx news yeah I want to watch
beef haven't seen it yet I'm sorry
Jake Kobe P for Johnny Daiquiri
Montgomery look at stranger things and
Power Rangers plus he's close to Tom
Holland's age don't know what that
really has to do with that uh does that
matter Human Torch and Spider-Man
friends they made it the Statue of
Liberty all the time they're like
confidants in each other's like personal
lives as well the point is here uh I
almost lost an eye
but yeah I think I think Decker
Montgomery would be a great pick and I
mean
I love that he can be funny right he's
funny he's got that like bravado funny
that he like struts around with he's
definitely got that bully energy in the
stranger things things we've seen but I
don't think he's that guy like in
interviews and stuff he seems like I
don't really know I don't remember his
performance in Power Rangers I don't
either but he seems like a really good
nice guy not just the bullying type so I
could see that and he's got the look The
the vibe and yeah the Tom Holland thing
is a really good point I really want to
see them like simpatico if Tom Holland's
gonna come back this stream has made me
realize I don't really follow up and
coming actors anymore yeah we're old now
I'm like I'm still like I still watch my
Keanu Reeves interviews and I'm looking
up for Harry Potter old interviews of
Robert De Niro and Al Pacino like that's
what I've been doing when I watch
interviews is like these old ass I mean
yeah
man I'm really out of the loop on
like younger actors now it's hard
um yeah that's kind of funny holy
who you want for Harry Potter I don't
know
some kid children audition let me know
good
I mean I remember thinking Daniel
Radcliffe sucked in that first movie he
was a child and I was a child when I saw
it yeah this other child sucks but you
would like see another activity 32 year
old Greg wouldn't be like that
sucks I don't like this kid I'm gonna go
on YouTube right now and be like this
child sucks
YouTube is like seven pages
as an adult I would be conscientious of
it as a fellow child I thought this is a
shitty actor
but then he got crazy I thought he
thought he evolved into a fantastic
Master Class of being around this
British actors of all time he's
literally being taught acting by the
teachers of Hogwarts Ben vaginal
um that's why these questions I've
noticed I've been drawing so many blinks
yeah it's interesting so I'm like oh I'm
not at into the no anymore yeah without
these like everyone talks I hear names
tossed around all the time like like
like Glenn Powell yeah like I hear that
all the time Glenn Powell you know I'm
Top Gun that's all I know everybody
wants some if you're not seen everybody
some what's everybody wants it's the
spiritual sequel to days and Confused
Richard Lincoln made about the 80s about
15 years later I've never seen daising
confused what
yeah you should it's great film I think
you'll really personally like both those
they're both like Day in the Life movies
they're really calming because it's just
like watching someone's life experience
I like those a lot like people will be
grown-ups with Adam Sandler it's not
that but it's good no and that's how I
describe
oh yeah you should you should watch both
you'll love them
um hey bajinaro I love your thumbnail uh
actors you would cast for Superman what
I'm loving in the chat right now is I'm
seeing a lot of people throwing in names
for Lois Lane and I really appreciate
that because I think Lois Lane very
important I wanna I mean I'll use this
opportunity really quick to talk about
like Zack Snyder was defending his
choice with have you seen this this
incredible interview the Russo Brothers
yeah that was one of the headlines that
I totally did not talk about uh but yeah
you can just listen to it it's a great
interview with him and the Russo
brothers and then they they're breaking
down the experience of Zack Saunders
Justice League the whole time which is
very conversational and they're they're
talking about their their methodology on
set and how they go and you hear the
differences in how they approach things
and you know in the sequels for Zack
Snyder's Justice League part of it was
supposed to be that they have um that
Batman would be like be with Lois Lane
and then eventually you know Superman
will come back into life and it would be
kind of like a Pearl Harbor situation
that classic Love Story someone
returning from war and he thought it
would give he the reason he wanted to do
what he said was he thought it would
give a really interesting character
Dynamic for Lois Lane who doesn't really
get that opportunity a lot and to really
utilize Amy Adam's skills like that was
part of it and it really goes against
you know what we like in comics but I
thought it was really fascinating that I
never looked at it from that angle
I yeah I think it's a it's a fundamental
character issue for how I perceive Lois
uh I don't think Lois you can do without
that story like Lois is a Pulitzer
prize-winning reporter do you think it
makes her a no I think like no
because I believe I was like wait a
second I forgot the you were about
to make and then it was immediately like
insulted the concept uh no I think Lois
Lane uh can do what she wants but I also
think that it's not a Lois Lane
character choice to be with Batman
Batman is kind of the antithesis of how
she sees the world it's not even about
Superman it's Lois Lane believes in the
good of people even through adversity
and Batman wants to believe in the good
of people Batman loves that Superman is
is this incredible super heroic above
Humanity figure that is alien once he
gets through his his fear of them
whereas he doesn't have that that
blindness of optimism and I think Lois
wouldn't be able to see what Bruce sees
the world with would you especially
back Snyder's face I think I'd like to
have a conversation with him I've talked
to him about his take on Batman and like
our discrepancies in it like when I've
talked to him about Batman we
fundamentally see like different
versions of the character but I don't
disagree with his take because the
character has been around so long I
think he just identifies with different
writers attachment to it it's so
archetypal but he and I just see Batman
differently and so this is a nice way to
put it
um for Superman Legacy okay so who would
you cast though for your Batman for
because we talked a lot about the
Superman Legacy casting Who Would You
cast though for your Batman brave in the
bulk uh I really like the Jensen Ackles
we've talked about I think Ben Barnes
would be great
um from Punisher uh the the counter to
John burnthal also from Narnia not bad
uh I think he's got that billionaire
bravado but also has a darkness in him
um I if Jake hadn't been Mysterio and
Jake Gyllenhaal wasn't like as big of a
movie star I think his Ness is that
because I think like prisoners Jake
Gyllenhaal and and like especially
Nightcrawler Nightcrawler Jake
Gyllenhaal is very close to a Bruce
Wayne to me like that Darkness but charm
um and I think that psychotic sociopath
he punches mentally ill people for a
hobby that's what the Batman well that's
the thing is like the Batman is Robert
Pattinson's take that's a little bit
more My Chemical Romance gloomy Nirvana
whereas I think Jake Gyllenhaal would
add that bravado that inherently comes
from being a movie star yeah see I don't
feel like the Batman the Brave and the
bow will lean into it that much I think
they're gonna have to make it the bigger
because they're not going to make the
movie Dark yeah they I feel like it's
it's such a touchy thing to me like
you're my third kid right it's like yeah
you're my you're not only the third
child you're my actual biological child
and I'm putting you through the ringer
and that bat family is going to be
really important so you need someone
that can have that like relationship
immediately like with Dick Grayson with
Damian I kind of hope James Gunn would
direct that one because when you see he
knows how to tell like that's what I
think the suicide squad demonstrated was
like he knew how to write that fine line
of exploring characters who have like
like lean into the darkness into the
trauma but somehow keep it vibrant and
fun yeah without it being like offensive
or tonally confusing yeah and I feel
like he would know how to do that I mean
mushidi if flash is as good as they say
I think will but that's a I think that
he's gonna direct Batman I feel like he
might lean a little too dark well yeah I
mean he definitely it looks dark but uh
and if they if I mean I I don't know uh
a lot of his dramatic work but something
Scott Adkins would be a really
interesting Batman uh the right age uh
actually doing the stunts actually yeah
right I think Scott Adkins would be
interesting you can act two yeah you can
but like I've just never seen that guy
John Wick
the fat guy who could fight
um all right here we go J Master thank
you Sony and Disney announced Sam Raimi
Spider-Man trilogy The Amazing
Spider-Man are now officially streaming
on Disney plus Spider-Man homecoming and
Venom will be on Disney plus uh on May
12th in the U.S uh thank you J Master
for that super chat I think some people
are really reading into this as as like
it's gonna mean some type of big change
for the MCU
um do you I don't really I haven't like
really looked into it that much as like
this big implication but I do want to
use this opportunity to talk about the
possible rumor that we've been hearing
of Venom three featuring uh let's have
come up in the chat a couple times Venom
and because maybe they are working out
some more of a deal to include more MCU
characters in their Shenanigans I mean
um they they even mentioned doctor
strange and across the spider verse yeah
sometimes you can't even like say a
name right so they even
mentioned Dr Strange and across the
spider verse and then in venom three
there's a big rumor that Owen Wilson is
going to be in there they haven't said
if it's going to be more Mobius or not
but it's going to be morbius actually
it's going to be more basic than a
vampire wow I like blonde yeah blood
tastes good I'm so sleepy during the day
look at this hot doctor why are you a
doctor you should be a model
you're so hot
[Laughter]
and a plasma
I want this movie so bad but uh yeah I
mean if if Mobius is in it and if it
because Madame Webb is really they
already have across the spider verse
dealing with Multiverse Shenanigans yep
then you have Madame Webb which will
deal with Multiverse Shenanigans and
then if Mobius is in it and if he's from
if if it is Owen Wilson's Mobius with
the TVA and then things are getting like
I wonder if because there's like
reliable people have reported on Owen
Wilson appearing in this and so to me it
seems like it would be a little odd if
the image somebody's the one to do it
but it would be a little odd if it
wasn't Mobius and it was just oh Wilson
is someone else tin foil hat Theory I
think when they were able to make the
new deal with Tom Holland to come back
as Spider-Man which is something that
happened a few years ago and then kind
of quietly Kevin feige tied Tom Holland
back into the universe saying Spider-Man
4 script was written they finally got
pen to paper they like where they're
going that is a more recent announcement
that that will be happening I think when
that deal went through I think the New
Deal was to tie in Sony characters into
Marvel in a broader way I think that
potentially we go from across the spider
verse through to beyond the spiderverse
and Beyond the spider-verse ties into
live action I do think that's gonna
happen I think Madame Webb is going to
have Madame Webb be wielding the web
tapestry of the universe that's going to
tie into the MCU and I do honestly think
that we're gonna have a situation where
Owen Wilson is chasing uh Deadpool in
Deadpool 3 because he has the time
Turner and he's messing with the TVA and
that affects Venom 3 tying it all into
one giant thing this is a crazy tempo of
that theory but I do honestly think
Mobius is going to be kind of like the
fun jet ski riding Nick Fury for
multiversal stuff and then Madam Webb is
going to be the one actually controlling
those things and I think it literally
starts with this Summer's across the
spider-verse I think it's about to get
the Multiverse we wanted Doctor Strange
to be I think we're about to get
involving the spiders but I'm hoping
that Tom Holland contained little corner
can say friendly neighborhood I hope we
get at least one or two friendly
neighborhood Spider-Man hijinks and
maybe use Andrew Garfield because I
think people want to back maybe use Toby
McGuire but we've never had anything
that big with two Studios I think that
was part of the new deal
this is what happens when you say oh
Wilson's going to be in venom three what
Coy's like well because if you look at
the TVA the TVA would affect the Sony
Universe the TVA would affect the spider
verse the TVA does affect all the Marvel
universes and we know that secret Wars
is coming so if you've got a set up in
these other Deadpool 3 Venom 3 spider
versus that could make it more
digestible to have all the fox
characters in secret war that can make
it more digestible to have the Kang
Dynasty which I honestly think the Kang
Dynasty is going to reveal that the
events of phase four art one Universe I
think there are things that happen in
the universe that are separate
multiverses that we've already lived
through that then we get tied together
more and more because Kevin feige has
said from the beginning you got to trust
in the process Russo's recently came out
and said they're taking some really big
swings and people don't realize it yet I
think honestly Kang Dynasty is going to
be Kang like connecting the universes in
a way that smashed them together leading
to Secret Wars and that includes Venom
and Deadpool 3.
that's what I think
yes boy
gentlemen Who We Got Tonight Garcia or
tank oh my money is on Garcia never bet
against the Latino guy
you know what I'm talking about yeah
it's uh it's about it's a fighting match
it's a boxing match so I actually don't
know that this match is happening oh my
god dude I I totally follow boxing
matches yeah yeah totally on Garcia
Tank's gonna go down that tank that
doesn't have enough fuel in the tank you
know what I mean to keep up with the
speediness yeah at the uh you know the
punch as of Garcia probably I imagine
Garcia tonight is gonna you know let
Tank just like kind of unload on him but
he's gonna be tiring him out so that way
he's roping him down at the end
um yep that's how it's gonna go I know
how these things go totally trust me
guys I I'm a I'm a boxing Enthusiast
that's what everyone here at the channel
knows me as totally that's why I'm
always in my PJs I'm studying fights
J Master Sony yesterday wait a minute
hold on a second he's following up here
uh thank you for the Super Chat yes boy
thank you for the Super Chat J Master
Sony yesterday announced on the press
release that more Sony Marvel movies and
shows also their Sony Library will be
streaming later this year on Disney plus
us they have worked out some kind of
deal yep and I feel like it might have
something to do with everything you're
talking about koi there's no Sony
streaming services I think it behooves
them I will hear about it again when I
do the playback for this see he get it
too that's why I went twice as long yeah
why you did it twice as long way to go
you thought ahead that's leadership
right boom ready with it way to go come
on thank you buddy
well you're like please don't be a third
no please let there be a third sorcerer
plus the new streaming service for all
magical Wizardry movies well JK rule the
only European and UK cast again
the EU and UK cast again JK Simmons is
he back are we back hey Google JK
Rowling oh was this talking about Harry
Potter yes okay I mean the name sorcerer
plus I'm assuming big fan okay
so is this I don't understand the
question
I understand the question
I'm just trying to put it together will
she be overseeing the cast I don't know
if she like over I think there was a
casting director
I don't understand I think she will have
a say in who the I feel like when the
movies first came out they she I imagine
her creative control has become more and
more as the franchise has progressed
especially by the time they got around
to Fantastic Beasts I think she had to
approve people in the beginning and then
it got to the point where are you sure
she did they usually don't give a
what the author thinks there's a lot of
actual like she gets money for
everything like yeah I know I imagine
that but I feel like especially like for
a first time like it was her only
book and then they made a movie
like did they have a say back then I
don't know but I know I mean if Hermione
is I think she's now canonically black
in the book so she would have to be
black she could probably get a more
diverse cast this time around yeah in
the play She's black right the in the in
the the first child yeah yeah so I
imagine that's the way they'll go so I
don't know if that's gonna be overseen
by you know I'm okay with them being
British all British actors I mean it's a
British like part of the school yeah
like there's there's American schools
that aren't Hogwarts so I just don't get
shitty 10 year old actors as long as
they're good make sure they're good
talented actors with a lot of life
experience so they could hone in on
their pain and suffering and use it as
an outlet they've lived dozens of months
where is their life experience yeah
people with life experience and let them
and let them only grow in the spotlight
so that way they kind of get better as
actors as time goes on
about children being cast in this show
because they want to make it like 10
years it is so weird it's putting kids
a weird spot to put a child in is
they're really lucky how Daniel
Radcliffe Emma and Ron turned out like
they're like Rupert Grint coming back in
M Night Shyamalan after years off I was
like oh he got to have a life and his
kids and Emma Watson just like they're I
don't think we've seen three people come
out of that as sane as those three you
know what I mean yeah I know again
hallow bib thank you so much for the
Super Chat halabave is saying Kate
Phillips for Supergirl woman of tomorrow
all right guys we're gonna look up who
Kate Phillips is do you know who Kate
Phillips is I don't all right coy so
it's time to go to the face I'm gonna
control Z everything all right he's
ready everybody don't worry guys that's
fine everything will be fixed in no time
watch Greg do his thing okay Kate
Phillips
all righty don't know her work
okay
okay okay so she's in Downtown Abby or
something the Downtown Abbey
Downtown Abbey that is Kate Phillips for
you all right gentlemen and who are they
saying Supergirl
she has the look I don't know the talent
I imagine she's British so she's
probably really talented they put the
work in in British acting classes they
really are I think I do think I I am
wondering though if it would be a little
bit odd to go back to someone who is a I
know if people don't like hearing this
I'm just saying you know you got to
consider the conversation that would
take place you just have to
and the arguments and social media like
you're you're putting a Latina actress
in as super girl in The Flash movie
which is probably going to be a massive
film I think it's gonna do okay
and then and then if you go back to just
a white blonde girl which honestly I'm
not like gonna yell at the screen if
they do that I'm not I think there will
be
I think there will be backlash though a
pretty big backlash to do to to make the
pendulum swing back I think no matter
what they'll be backlash of course so I
don't really like and I'm just trying to
prevent everything I'm trying to keep
everything safe around here in the comic
book world where everyone's mad and then
when something comes out we stop being
mad because we don't care anymore we
just want to see the thing and it's
exciting to see it everyone's mad in the
lead-up but no one really gives a
after just every time I think it's just
gonna be uh casting someone that's right
for the role and then watching their
movie that's what I think that's what I
mean no matter what someone's gonna be
mad that's what I think too I'm on the
same page as you I'm gonna just really
quickly check the super chats everyone
can you can you just bear with Greg as
he uh with us everything you want to
read the live chat yeah then yeah yeah
check the live chat okay we got uh
someone saying Puff the Magic Dragon
inexplicably not sure why but I'm
excited for them well you guys are
watching Love and Death Elizabeth Olsen
uh if I have time I try to watch
everything I can uh Kate Phillips
apparently Linda Shelby oh Arthur's wife
from peaky blinders that is on that is
the fifth showdown of my must watch I've
never watched peaky blinders because
it's it's many many hours uh it looks
great and two of my favorite
actors aren't it uh with MCU shows
special features and movies any scope
for actors who have acted in the MCU who
wants to direct Karen Dylan Brie Larson
Clark Greg to get involved behind the
camera I hope so I know Chris Evans
really wants to direct I'd love to see
him come back and maybe direct something
like a special
um presentation like they you know Mike
giaccino Michael giacchino made uh the
man thing Mike Chino Mike gioccino
Scott makes the best pastries in the
North End uh and I think that uh
giacchino really showed another giant
skill set with introducing us to man
thinking World by Night I'd love to see
Chris Evans get to direct I'd love to
see Brie Larson get to tell a story
because I feel like she gets attacked
very publicly maybe she's behind the
scenes like her name won't be like I'm
mad at this person for existing uh so
yeah I'd love that
okay it's 2 A.M here and watching you
guys now thanks daruka at pachar uh what
did I think of Beau is afraid I think it
is such a Trippy experience that it had
been in my top five of the year for the
first two and a half hours and then the
last 20 minutes lost me so much that it
actually dropped like two full letter
grades I loved it until the last 20
minutes so much and then I was like I
don't uh so uh I need to read up on why
the ending was what it was maybe but I I
had really loved it up until the end
that's surprising to hear man what was
that just because like I can't imagine
it the last 20 minutes it affected it
that much the movie's like five hours
long and that's so much I just like the
last 20 minutes that is so strange it
just didn't stick the landing of what
it's promised to me really yeah to to a
level where it was a a minus down to C
yeah we'll look what I could do in the
Stream now
okay sorry guys
Wipeout
I did see Renfield uh I have a review on
my page I really enjoyed it and uh if
you've gotta love like blood gore and
crazy action it's very like sardonically
big and I really enjoyed that uh Robert
Kirkman wrote the story uh who did
invincible and it's got that Invincible
blood and gore and then uh Chris
Brewster who is the hallway fight
violent oh it's insanely violent I
thought it was PG-13 no it's one of the
hardest R blood movies I've seen in a
while really bananas insane I really
want to watch no it's a Nutty thing it's
like a it's like a cult horror movie
with invincible's blood
oh sweet it's crazy Johnny
is asking favorite Michael Jackson song
and favorite album I don't really know
uh I like the greatest hits
I think bad uh black or white
um Smooth Criminal like those are all
like the classics those stick out but
for a reason I think black or white
might be my favorite music video
um so I'm gonna go with that one I'm
gonna go with do you remember oh that
means you could have had Magic Johnson
and
oh who was the model in it I forget her
name
um but Cindy Crawford she was very
attractive
Eddie Murphy was in it no and and
it's my favorite because that's when I
learned how to roll my tongue with
Michael Jackson when he goes like
and I wanted to learn how to do it yeah
so I I practiced and somehow I figured
it out just sat there listening to the
Michael Jackson
Off The Walls great album
I agree G call BP Sean Chandler doesn't
know
you tell Sean Chandler Greg's coming for
him he's taking down the stream he did
uh I I don't think that was the the
length of the movie uh I don't know like
what what Sean's issues were with it
he's a nice guy uh electron but it was
just the last 20 minutes fundamentally
erased the first two and a half for me
it happens man
jorian cuiva thank you for the Super
Chat just stumbled on your live stream
greetings from the Netherlands I always
love here Thriller is the one of the
greatest music videos of all time I'll
just just to stumble back to this
question for just a brief second I saw
Thriller they played it before the um
that Eli uh Roth movie the is it
either Roth yeah Roth movie a house with
a clock in the walls and they they IMAX
formatted the Michael Jackson oh that's
very dope and I was like this I've seen
that musical countless times but then
watching it there you know this is like
terrifying and so fun yeah that's
awesome it is it is probably my all-time
favorite music video
um the the Thriller music videos amazing
Aki tamachi I'm very excited for the
boys season four I love the boys and uh
this season looks to be Madness
uh and everybody put in the chat where
you're from I love finding art people
are watching food yeah finding someone
from the Netherlands that's cool I'm
hearing someone from from uh I would I
would when I went to Zurich I met people
who were from Switzerland who um
Iman my bad I'm sorry Aisha I totally
came across super racist I named the
wrong model everyone looks the same to
you
well yeah
Conor McGregor is having you on my life
I know I'm just here to represent my
people in Dublin and the Fighting Irish
that's why nobody's hiring me because I
look like Conor McGregor yeah
Carolina England
Ontario Austria dude we got like a crazy
we got a bunch of people holy I was
like I don't know what you're naming and
then I saw this I'm having a stroke I'm
just reading a map oh sorry
Nebraska Norway Ohio the UK Dawson
Wales it's Darth Maul's Planet oh I was
like that's bad but it's a place uh
Wales that's awesome Welsh accents are
the best Left Coast U.S uh India England
this is dope man I always wonder like
what we're impact Mississippi
yeah the one non-racist the ATL
New Zealand dope man this is cool um
Tony okay man I love South Africa Cape
sounds good people here thank you so
much Argentina this is everywhere but
locally yeah no one's from California no
there's one left coaster they're all on
John Campbell you never ask me anything
that's what they're doing they're very
busy Sri Lanka that's awesome oh I got
more reach reactions coming thank you
guys thank you guys so much for being
here
Tony movie chappie D9 Neo blomkamp I'm
assuming the rest of that name
um thank you so much
who do you think is the blame for the
mess of the DCU Zach Snyder Josh Sweden
or the old regime of Warner Brothers and
what do you want to see from James Gunn
and Peter saffron DC Universe it's a
very general question I think we can
answer it well I feel like it does not
fall on one person I mean usually the
the motto is you go to the leader to
kind of see what happened with the
organization of everything and the
farmer things with all the DCU was just
disorganized all around and I don't feel
like it just like I I don't even really
think of Joss Whedon as part of the the
thing to blame I think it's just a lot
went wrong in that regard I can't you
can't say it on I just to put a plan
simple you can't put it on one person no
for that for what happened there it was
just an all-around mess with a lack of
confidence and a lack of unity with
behind the scenes so of course you're
not going to find Unison with your
audience yeah you know like you're just
not going to and uh what I want to see
with going forward with James Gunn and
Peter Safran is pretty simple like
that's why I loved watching The Suicide
Squad was it James Gunn I feel like has
this unique gift
where it's weird when you go on Twitter
because it seems like everyone like
hates them now but when you when
you watch like the suicide squad or even
the Guardians movies there's very few
people let's take how Coy was talking
about Ari Esther recently you know Ari
asked her to make these experimental
horror films and as he evolves he gets
less in tune with his audience like he
just gets more away whereas James Gunn
manages to maintain this few people can
do something that's weird and
experimental but not cross the line too
far to the point where you alienate
yourself from your audience and he knows
how to make strange and weirdness
attainable for mainstream audiences and
that's what I'm hoping he is able to
achieve here when adapting or bringing
Oddities to life and being able to shine
a light on things exciting comic books
and I've citing specific comic runs
which can't just be one-to-one
adaptations
um
what is the phrase you say adaptation
versus translation translation you
cannot just translate yeah
um you can't just do translations like
that so I I really have a lot of faith
in James especially
re-watching suicide The Suicide Squad
and re-watching the Guardians films I'm
like
this guy is a fantastic film really nice
like we should have all the faith in the
world's gonna do a great job the amount
of crap we get for having belief in
someone that's proven themselves 20
times over is preposterous I would want
to kind of study a little bit more of
the films he's only produced to see how
he is as on the inputs because that's
where I feel like JJ Abrams has a lot of
strength I think JJ Abrams is a
wonderful producer yeah
um and he does not even try to get
credit a lot of the time whereas James
Gunn it's like I can think of a few
things like the Bellco experiment or uh
brightburn movies I thought were okay
yeah
um but I want to see what he's like as a
like what does he like as a creative
producer though yeah you know but I feel
like a lot more things will be I feel
like what we'll get a lot of is Story by
James Gunn and someone else I think he's
gonna be big in the overseeing yeah
Story by and then written by right not
him maybe not him written by but
there'll be a lot of Story by him is
going to be really involved with the
outlining yeah I think he's going to be
an even more public-facing Kevin flagy
of running a lot of things and I think
that he's already announced things in
really wonderful way so what I want to
see is more comic book love for my
biases but also people acknowledging
like that's the foundation of all this
and I think that's what they're doing
now I think that the Anchor Point should
have always been the comics and now it
is and I think that's inherently going
to make it more cohesive because you've
got something to point to you've got
something that's structured you've got
something that's already worked there's
so many Comics that like I know people
think Comics don't sell but they do and
there's a reason that you can look at
like oh this did well that means it's
already connected that means that story
has already worked at drawing people in
so adapt that story and you've also got
a universe that is freshly restarting
with a plan so I honestly think that
we're gonna blame the reactionary
concept that Warner Brothers is going
with and I think the goal is to not be
reactionary going forward
that's what I think sometimes I think
about actresses
who are like once married to these super
famous people and what it must be like
see them on screen like watch a movie
later like Jenna Fisher and James Gunn
were together oh I didn't know that and
now he's like Superstar Chris Pratt and
Eleanor Ferris yeah yeah I remember that
and it's like
what must that be like do you think they
rub it in their faces I think it'd be
weird to like
I think beware about like premieres and
stuff like when you're like at an event
and you got to be like ah my ex is here
but you're like publicly facing on
camera the whole time that wouldn't be
fun Top Gun and gives us a moment of
silence he went way too high into the
sky appreciate the Super Chat though
Diego Guevara thank you senor
koi that was racist and I feel good
about it finally gotta get it off my
chest
hi I'm new to these streams thank you so
much for being here I was just wondering
Coy how do you feel about quake
did you watch Agents of Shield I've seen
some of it I've seen enough to know
Quake is here's the funny thing about
Quake if quake and the potential secret
Invasion Wars appearance the funny thing
about
um Quake is I've never seen a single
episode of Agents of Shield
yet I have heard so long about how
amazing Chloe Bennett is yeah as quick
so much so I know her name
I've never ever say I have no idea what
her performance is like and people are
jazzed about the possibility of her
appearing in secret Invasion Secret Wars
and I'm excited for Agents of Shield
fans to potentially get that cathartic
rewarding experience to actually feel
acknowledged the one that one I feel
like should have had the easiest time
being acknowledged yeah because it
directly came it was supposed to be and
it had Clark Greg and I believe Sam
Jackson cameo at one point Sif at Sif
yeah like they had actual MC like real
MCU tie-ins yeah and Joss Whedon uh
kicked it off and his brother Jed and um
and uh Marissa tantrum they they uh they
spearhead the show with the show Runners
so yeah I feel like it should have been
40 dollars so it's kind of weird that it
hasn't but I think that Chloe getting uh
she seems in love with the character so
I'm excited for the actress to come back
and I'm also excited for the fans so I I
think it's a great idea the tone of the
show wasn't really my jam as far as like
my experience of TV that's not my thing
but I think that her being in the
greater universe is a win-win for
everyone and man she people in this chat
right now are like praising the hell out
of them she's also made it into the
comics which is cool like the character
is translated from the show to the
comics and was she an original for the
show yeah oh that's amazing so now she's
in a comic so like she got this must be
something then I mean people love it and
I'm happy for them it's like I I don't
like uh soap operas but it's a big
Market I don't like uh you know country
music but people love it like it's just
not my tone so I have nothing against
Agents of Shield it's just not my dream
I don't like Evangelical channels but
it's for a lot of people but I only
watched them once a week though to get
my weekly duties in just gotta make sure
he cleanse Von Rouse
Supergirl and Superman can ask why
shouldn't Superman super Randy White I I
don't know what's going on here what are
you guys talking about have you got to
that point in the Stream where
everyone's fighting that's my favorite
part fight my favorite fight kill each
other
um Von Rose what do you guys think about
the Russo brothers and directing Batman
brave in the Bold also cool I need
another ranking video soon please yeah
he's gonna work on Guardians yeah that's
happening this week and include quake in
that ranking um what do you guys think
of the Guardians movies and Agents of
Shield
I would love for the Russo Brothers to I
mean
the Russo Brothers have two voices it
seems
comedy or falcon or the the Winter
Soldier right now
handheld gritty action which I love
um they really got these two things but
uh
it would be cool for them to step in I
would like to see them step into DCU I
owe you more fascinated to see a a
director who's maybe not as associated
with that
um because because I feel like they
would kind of go for the grittiness of
it where I kind of want like a for me my
my the want I would have is to have a
polished look about it yeah like because
I think it needs to be the opposite of
the Batman it needs to have a different
feel yeah I want a colorful world I
think so many people want a more like
Hokey Batman every time I got excited
about Pattinson we're like yeah we've
had that we want the Adam West so let
them have their animals I think
it's gonna be a lot shinier and I think
that's gonna fit the Justice League
better so I don't know if the russos are
necessarily the right people for Batman
uh I also feel like they they said they
were interested and then like two days
later they were like that's not true we
were just tired it just said Batman so I
don't know like the reality of any of it
uh but I I personally like I loved the
gray man so I have yet to have a Miss
for the Russo Brothers as far as my
experience of them I also also think
they're really invested in the world of
comic books so I I think that if they
want to do it great if they don't
I I could see it being a totally
different tone than what they would make
so I like Kyle frith's uh pitch in the
Stream right here where he's saying
Russo Brothers should direct a green
arrow film or show with Charlie Charlie
underrated and I think uh yeah Green
Arrow film but from the rooster brothers
that will work he looks so much like
green air like I love Charlie Hunnam's
look it'd be perfect and King Arthur was
so slept on I love guys excuse me the
thing is that you know with green arrow
especially is they took Green Arrow and
that when they made the show Arrow they
made it Batman they made him Batman they
did it's like dark brooding and gritty
and it is the billion and then the
background came in and they were like oh
there's a Batman and the arrow was like
uncomfortable because he was like that's
another guy like me where as like arrows
kind of fun yeah it was a blast and if
you're bringing in certain characters
that like he allows a certain element of
comedy and levity in that Darkness how
far to the Arrow show did you go uh
season two did you not like season two I
just like I love season a high volume
show there's just so many hours there
was there was a lot of there was one I
think it was season five the arrow is
the only DC CW Show I completed wow and
the um the there's one season where or
he's in prison oh it's so good I've
heard that that's uh that was originally
gonna be a movie they were gonna make a
green arrow uh hyper Max movie and then
they turned it into the show and and uh
dude Stephen Amell killed so good middle
than that but I do think Charlie Hunnam
would crush
sure yeah like and I think he uh also
Charlie Hunnam maybe is the most con
um fandom based person that surprised me
he loves con culture he loves Khan fans
he loves those pokes to the point where
he brought Garrett Headland Megacon as
like a friend so like Garrett Hedland
was there to like you know talk the Tron
world but it was because Charlie Hunnam
loves Khan so much and him and Garrett
have been friends for like 20 years so
he was like no no you'll love this so I
was really impressed with Charlie's love
for like the con cultures that makes me
want him to be someone like green arrow
that would get that love back
all right here we go here we go Diego
Guevara just also wanted to say that
I've been watching you since 2014.
you're my main inspiration to start my
own YouTube channel going on right now
do you hop into everyone's YouTube
stream and say that same exactly
different year are you hoarding your
compliments out to other streams control
C control V just rip because you don't
specify real rejects here oh that's true
when did they start doing the channel
check they launch okay
that sounds believable
all right thank you no Diego thank you
it's a lot if you ever see me in person
please come say hi I would love to brush
you off I mean like I'm busy right now
can't you see I'm working out
at this Italian restaurant dude
starts doing push-ups on the street I
would love I would love to take a photo
with you one day are you wearing a
headband here
[Music]
I got the curls for it it's true I think
you kind of need the curves it does
because I couldn't have that got the
fluff yeah and any other forehead size I
do I I'm lucked out yeah foreign
YouTube channel I do it does just got my
name real reject that's where it is
that's you just type in real rejects
coli and then you find it totally just
touching my nipple here on here
what's going on
[Laughter]
we've hit two and a half hours and Craig
has lost it happens man
um crooked thank you crooked Daisy
Ridley for Sue storm duh
coin's reality are super villain facial
I keep up the good work guys I think you
need to put Rogaine on your cheeks and
just see what happens I would love it if
your beard outgrows the center and I do
have these big Wolverine shops yeah that
would be he's giant am I too
white now to do interviews um I think
they only look whiter well Daisy really
is gonna be way too busy now that's true
that's true I'm happy for him now that
she's gonna be starring in some Star
Wars stuff yeah
um but I don't think she would be a bad
Sue storm I'm not that familiar with her
work outside of Star Wars and I feel
like she got a bad rep when it came to
an unfair criticism from certain fan
bases when it came to Rey like granted
don't get me wrong I don't think the
writing of those a lot of that stuff was
especially rise I think rise of
Skywalker really is a number but I think
if you isolate Daisy Ridley's
performance even Last Jedi I think she
does a great job
koi's comic Corner did not come to a
conclusion uh the amount of love I've
gotten for Lily has been incredible
we're literally doing a Guardians
ranking though it's coming back uh it's
just been there's not been a lot of like
positive news or stuff that is in that
structure but quiz common corner still
alive
hey
ask Greg hey
we got the
we got we needed the solo trailers yeah
I counted what solo trailers the
Spider-Man the trailer oh yeah that was
just now that was like two weeks ago I
thought my brain went to Alden Solo
movie and I was like I reacted to that
trailer recently what a weird thing to
do and why don't I remember it
Jason Todd
thank you Jason Todd
that's it that's the whole thing how do
you guys feel about James Gunn saying
rocket is the true antagonist of the
Guardians trilogy
ah I see it I
wait and antagonist did you mean
protectors yeah protagonist I think you
meant the protagonist which had the
wrong word yeah I think I think he is
the hardened soul of it in so many ways
I mean it's obvious it's like the lead
is Star Wars that is Star-Lord it's
Star-Lord uh but the protag even in
Guardians 2 you know like he's the one
who has the most struggle to deal with
and it and it's I love
I love seeing the trailer for Guardians
3 and then re-watching Guardians 2
knowing like oh man this this Trilogy
just makes so much more sense now
knowing especially what they're what
they've done with rocket raccoons
one of the best hardest person to come
around to like I love his portrayal of a
character of a guy who's like like a
professional as like yondu puts
it like he's a professional
um but the relationship they flesh out
with him in Groot like where he's the
dad of them yeah and he really is the
protector yeah he's the protector of the
Guardians more than more than Star-Lord
he really is the one who will go out of
his way even though he gets him in
trouble
it'll get him out of trouble he'll
sacrifice anything for his friends like
that's his family and now they're here
to go save him from a situation you know
and and it's like people think he's
going to die but I think Rocket's the
one who deserves the happy ending
because he's got the most tragic
backstory and the fact that we do see
his uh comic book girlfriend in it makes
me hope we get the walk away into the
sunset I would not like it if he died
um from a story
I think Drax dying makes sense from a
story standpoint yeah
um but I don't I feel like rocket dying
is kind of me
I hope you enjoyed your run he just
suffers that's it like let him have a
happy ending he deserves a happy ending
and I feel like James Gunn will reward
rocket with I hope that this is all a
big mislead but I think everyone but
bantus ties
I don't think so I I think I think I
think quill and Gamora still make it out
alive but I just don't think they're
going to end up together okay I feel
like part of Quill's journey is him
learning to let go I would like that I
would love if we see an a not you know
romantic happy ending I think quill
needing to be his own man is going to be
really important yeah
nappy I'm gonna put out a video for the
few people who have asked about this
several times uh not watching Superman
and low with season three right now I
mean the bottom line is guys is like I
like over here
I got a operation oh my God I I
have more people here that I have hired
now and then like time is always short
enough the essence and and trying to
factor out what is the thing that
prioritize the most and Superman and
Lois you know like I try getting help
for that one just to make the time
forward with season two and didn't even
break even
um on covering it as much as I love the
show like I love the show it didn't
break there's a lot of shows I love that
I don't cover here because I'm like Ted
laughing like yeah I mean I love Barry
yeah I feel like Barry's a big show but
still didn't cover here as I wasn't sure
about it and then on on our patreon even
it would average like we got a couple
thousand patrons but we would only
average like literally for the watch
alongs like 10 to 14 people on the
average for season two so some people I
I don't like making things about money
when talking about certain choices that
we made I really don't
um at the same time it is one of the
factors for like every one of those
gonna take quite some time to put
together and it affects us in the
algorithm negatively and then it'll it
doesn't really get enough views yeah I
don't think people realize that part is
like if a video does badly it's not just
that video it's it's a it's a
repercussion and it's like the hours of
editing people don't equate and
sometimes the Saving Grace is like well
at least people that are patreon are
watching so at least a lot of times the
goal is like just break even yeah
sometimes that is just my bare minimum
just break even uh but when I'm not even
breaking even then I'm like well I gotta
pay you know the editors who I help who
I hire to help out for like the theaters
aren't at any other on the one editing
right
and then the other time for the re-edits
and whatever and this guy and
then me other people you see here on the
channel and John has a lot of problems
I don't I respect people's beliefs
I loved Father's Day
I think everyone has the right to keep
I've never seen them to themselves the
movie was tough telling me like such an
encouragement I had I think the deeper
message of Father Stu about just
sticking by your beliefs and finding and
I thought it it was a rare movie where
it was like they kept it real and for
the most part in the dialogue and the
portrayal and they also I just realized
my window pull is falling off oh right
now it is yeah um but also looked up to
Jesus I weirdly like the movie fathers
do quite a bit and I was moved to tears
in the movie I was like this is a
beautiful story hell yeah and I'm not
going to become Catholic but I just love
I kind of love the movie and when my
wife's grandmother was in town she's a
Catholic and uh I took her to church for
an hour and a half and I attended so
yeah listen online because it's not for
me I respect people's religions I do
I just think everyone's open to be made
fun
we could make a joke out of anyone
doesn't mean I don't respect I make fun
of everyone equal opportunity equal
opportunity doesn't mean I don't respect
your action when it comes down to it
doesn't mean I don't respect it
what am I trying to say here Tyler
no
[Music]
Tony movie Chaffee 90.
this is a real like uh
serendipitous streaming turn into
virtually calm and we're riding the wave
today
sorry
movie Jeffy D9 uh random question but
what are your favorite some of your
favorite comic book guilty pleasures
mine is a Hellboy reboot and Ghost Rider
spirit of Vengeance and spawn ooh ooh
that's a fun question I love that
question blade Trinity for sure I get so
much joy at a blade Trinity and I know
it's not like the caliber of Blade one
and two fun movie yes that's I think the
definition of guilty pleasure is knowing
it's not like good but enjoying your
time with it so definitely Blade Trinity
I'm not gonna lie guys I do not like
Batman Forever and Batman and Robin I
don't even get a guilty pleasure fun at
it I get guilty pleasure fun out of them
if you show me a clip but for two hours
you asked me to sit down with that
it is so hard to do yeah
um I like League of Extraordinary
Gentlemen that is good Gilmer in the
chat said that League of Extraordinary
Gentlemen that is a fun movie
I saw it as a kid maybe I wouldn't like
it now good night thuruca appreciate you
being here but yeah I I quite enjoyed
that film it was fun oh wait to be
impressed I haven't seen this since
theaters I want to re-watch it now oh it
is a terrible film yeah but it is so fun
last Sean Connery movie being that is
just dark kind of hustle love Street
Fighter which is not a comic book movie
but I love Street Fighter I've seen that
countless times that's one of those
movies like a weirdly quote I can't
think one of them but Blade Trinity
what's another like good
I think that the Ghost Rider spirit
Avengers movie is a blast
um I haven't seen it's uh directed like
super energetically by the crank guy so
it's a lot of fun and Nicholas Cage is
having a damn good time
um I think the the Fantastic Four movies
are a little like abused by the time but
like they they're well cast they're fun
I don't think I
Daredevil I saw the directors kind of oh
Daredevil director is actually good it's
good I actually like it I don't think Mr
Benz goes to play this is good Mr Man is
just a good movie Punisher war zone was
a movie I defended as a film that I
thought it knew exactly what it wanted
to be I don't think it's so bad it's
good like I think every bit of campiness
is very intentional I agree I think Ray
winstone's having a damn good time yeah
it's so over the top gory it's
ridiculous yeah I think it knows exactly
what it is I like I liked it a lot so
yeah I would probably go with League of
Extraordinary Gentlemen I think that is
a really fun movie
yeah like all these like random classic
characters yeah on screen it's so stupid
you know that was originally supposed to
be a fox uh version of secret orbs that
was going to be like the Daredevil Ghost
Rider all that and X-Men coming together
for like this big movie right around the
Marvel thing really yeah that was
supposed to be there's like a script
written it's a huge thing
I would love to read that me too I like
that's one of my goals is to get to the
point where I can get the old scripts
from these movies that never got made to
just experience them TMT Secret of the
Ooze I really like a lot oh that's a fun
one I like all three of those Ninja
Turtle movies
um Tyler hi guys do you want the new
Superman we need to start sending timers
here we're running short on time I got
to do okay you got nothing nothing
you're a bum I'm just gonna go I don't
know walk around
just your neighborhoods you'll see when
you're roller skating later just
wondering oh they like the aliens and
signs just to and fro and around your
yard Tyler hi guys you want the new
Superman to have the red trunks also do
you want the villain to be Lex or
someone new
I want it to be someone new I think I
think that is James Gunn safety net I
think to do the weird experimental I
feel like you keep Superman traditional
like whatever you do with the casting
and give us a villain you would not
expect someone weird that the masses are
being introduced then you can really
just showcase especially if he's
directing it like give us the weird one
yeah and you know sometimes he doesn't
do like Ronan the Accuser to give him a
pass because I was his first MCU film
but then I think he did a really strange
job with ego The Living Planet The
Suicide Squad while there's not like a
super definitive villain I thought what
they did with stara was awesome and then
the other people in the military was a
great threat High evolutionary looks to
be Great Peacemaker I thought an
excellent job so yeah I I think do
something very bizarre for for your
Superman villain I think that he's been
on red trunks make it happen oh yeah red
trunks for sure like without a doubt I
think they're necessary but I I also
think that the way to do it is cast a
very clean Superman your guy and then
play around with the lore the mythology
the lowest Lane the relationships and I
do think they need a different Dynamic
than just Alex Luther to kick off this
universe so I think maybe have him cast
introduce him but don't make him the
villain just have him like a long
Palpatine grow out like I want Lex to be
the long game yeah oh yeah I agree keep
build up to Lex but cast him like have
him in it but just not up front yeah
oh man
um Barry Allen in the chat speeding on
into our super chats
I thought a rhyme that I realized I just
said the same word again
um why can't John Humphrey be a gigolo
because John humped for free that's what
we used to say in school we used to be
like John Humphrey and then we kick him
we could kick him in the stomach twice
not on the ground he's humping for free
spit on him as we speak now he gets laid
like a mofo out in the game just doing
his work people were like oh John you
know I feel so sorry for him and his
upbringing with being bullied just
living that life smashing left and right
he's the adult star we want a cast in
the MCAS
dead shot thank you so much for being
here
um hey guys so first Greg did you watch
Evil Dead arise and his review soon no
I'm going to react to it because it
looks like a blasty blast Scream Six
coming next week
second question for you think Pratt
could be Hal Jordan real quick I'm gonna
say no
um did you talk to Kiana about the MCU
wouldn't even dare but do you think
Pratt could be a Hal Jordan no I I think
Hal Jordan's got more of a stoicism than
Pratt does I also think that Pratt has
like kind of aged out of that wanting to
do another 10 or 15-year commitment even
if they turn him into a villain soon
which I think would be short-sighted I
don't think Pratt's the guy for it uh I
did not talk to piano at the MCU because
I I would much rather talk but count
about like philosophy and life yeah like
I don't generally like talking to actors
about work like I like talking actors
about like life because they have a
different perspective on it than a lot
of people so I'm more interested in
actors interest than their work uh yeah
I know I would love I mean especially
keanu's had a lot of crazy like there
are questions I want to ask him but I
wouldn't want to camera pointed at me
same questions and I had a few of those
while there were cameras and I was like
there are things I would I I would be
like I feel uncomfortable
having this I wouldn't like be like let
me talk about your actual traumatic
but I would want to ask questions that
might like into subjects like that yeah
and he's very available on camera which
a lot of people aren't for like real
moments but I also wouldn't want there
to be an inherent like oh this is
forever if I want to talk about
something that's real yeah so that's I
don't and I don't ramp the MCU with
people a lot true true Dan I would
though I would chill
uh Dan v900
fix basically
oh look at that so clean get your stop
oh that's right we can look here I keep
doing this I don't have me too
let's just raise that there we go okay
uh DMV 900. how about something less
controversial like the current uh thanks
for the Super Chat like the current
Amazing Spider-Man run by Zeb welbs why
does Marvel editorial hate Peter Amazing
Spider-Man 24 with MJ's kids actually
being Paul's is horrible just awful
awful I agree oh I am really struggling
because I hate Spider-Man I hate the way
they're treating Spider-Man so I'm I
collect Amazing Spider-Man I am 29
issues away from every single Spider-Man
in print that's Sensational Peter Parker
web of unlimited everything ultimate uh
tangled web and I collect them so I'm
buying these issues that are inherently
not Spider-Man to me they're making a
meme they're making him a bully they're
making him Toby Maguire don't love it uh
and I I personally don't identify with
that take and there's a couple issues
Joe Kelly wrote that are black cat
dating issues that really sung and
showed me the dichotomy even more of
like this is what your Amazing
Spider-Man can be what are you doing so
I'm struggling because it is not my
Spider-Man and they just haven't
respected Peter in a really long time uh
I think the Miles Morales book is
exceptional right now and I think that
that's also really hard because those
characters can be so different and I
feel like since miles is like trying to
go through his Underdog figure out who
he is like but what if Peter's a dick
I'm like you they're differently
underdogs let him be the underdog he is
so I'm with you I love Jonathan Jr's art
but I am not dead writing currently uh
really quick guys I just wanted to say
thank you to everyone who has
contributed to our super chats I'm going
to be turning them off now because we
have to end within uh 18 minutes
so thank you to all much appreciated
though seriously seriously you kept us
keep just going because we have a limit
for how the latest we can go but even if
we happen to exceed it we will we're
gonna get them all done uh we were I
stick true to that there's still
stickers available though
but I love when you turn off the music
I Gotta show you guys what it says when
you turn on YouTube ominous we try to
turn off the super chats it's hilarious
so let me see if I can just show you
hold on everyone oh yeah oh yeah
it says like if you continue your fans
will no longer see super cats certainly
I understand the implications of this
action it's just so harrowing I
understand oh no we accepted the
implications we have accepted all
implications of this let me just do a
refresher here all right all right I got
the last effect to Kate Phillips but you
can still read uh okay contest my belly
don't start a typo I'd love uh nobody
John Wick uh yep I I think that universe
is pretty Lush I'm excited for the
Continental
um let's see starring Mel Gibson it is
sorry Mel Gibson uh everyone's happy
about that the fact that koi is a
sweating nerd I appreciate you the laser
uh yeah the the book is not loving uh
Spider-Man to me but you know hopefully
it shifts soon even the goblin story is
poor I agree 11 people read these comics
in the chat this makes me so happy these
are comic fans in here uh his death was
in a network comic phones uh recipes
King of the sweat is like great
challenge snap I do miss that man very
dearly uh he would have loved Modoc uh
let's see love your honors okay now I
can't read them oh I can read this
little window uh love when AME gives him
the nope can't see the end of that I do
I think Nova's coming Guardian three I
do think Nova is coming in Guardians 3.
I think Guardians 3 is going to uh allow
the cosmic Universe to go on without the
Guardians I think the Guardians as a
team retire I think maybe there's uh
like rosenbaum's character and and
Stallone I don't think they keep going
but I do think characters will be
introduced that go more Cosmic like Nova
yes yes
Christians unpronounceable
sanequa Martin green as storm
koi if you don't know who this is you're
an official racist listen I don't I
don't know uh
we had to look up because Jonathan
Tucker for you who is us is not a black
guy so I'm not a racist let's look up
some necqua Martin green I got you
covered Coy I'll bring it in this is
just for me I'll bring it in you because
you know this person of course I know
that's friends of course I know okay I
know all people of
yeah she's she's of color Okay out of
all people no
I don't recognize her work there you go
really tiny frame rate looks like she's
in Star Trek Discovery by this Walking
Dead Homie walking I didn't want yeah
okay uh I don't know where it works but
I can't um really comment because like
that's part of the the energy she's very
talented actress and if you care to
watch people outside of your color you
would actually appreciate her talents I
see I see if I cared this is the problem
with America and our comic book movies
yep
Cameron Singh what did your Super Chat
say
I don't give it a shot right in here
again we got you we got you dude I mean
come on look at this madness we got on
screen look how organized it is so clean
nothing gets missed now
we're in frame your chats and frame the
Super Chat is highlighted look at that
um XX late Torres txx that a sexy ass
name I love it thank you for the Super
Chat he says hey guys
Greg I want you to fix this
you got it buddy I've been watching you
guys for years now and I'm happy to see
how much you guys have blown up over the
years thank you sometimes I walk around
going wow everyone here has no idea who
I am I even watched your first live
stream with Tyrone Magnus really
um I don't remember doing that uh oh I
do remember that yeah that was fun
anyway I think we're all due for a
static shock thoughts
I absolutely would love a static shock
um I don't know who I would get to play
static shock uh but maybe maybe Caleb
McLaughlin he's a stranger so good and
like the few scenes that gave him the
near the finale were like so powerful I
also met him at the Creed 3 premiere and
he was so different than I expected he's
like a very intensely focused guy that
like really commands and and like
receives a 10 like he's really with you
but there's this energy of like
intensity which felt like static shock
and static shock has that like he's
always the center of attention even on
Team Dynamics like there's this really
cool like I'm the guy and he's got this
very like uh lead character energy in
real life uh and I really liked Caleb's
whole vibe also he um the the kid in
Creed the the daughter of Michael B
Jordan's character
um was a huge fan of Caleb and came over
and was like geeking out and signing and
really cute and Caleb like sat on the
floor cross-leg and like I talked for a
while and I connected I was like this
guy is not only talented but he's like
really great because everyone was trying
to get his attention and he was like
talking and I was so amazing like he's a
really good dude from that interaction I
don't know but like that was really
impressed that's really nice to hear
yeah like caleblock like I like nice
celebrities
I was just saying thanks to Coy for
inspiring me to start reading comics I
recently got Superman All-Star and
Kingdom Come any recommendations also hi
Greg wanted to shout this one out
specifying because he did do it he did a
Super Chat apparently nothing showed as
you can see Shenanigans here look at the
timing oh look at the perfect timing on
that look at that magic we got you
covered there it is here at the Super
Chat Nation
he said All-Star and kingdom come and
ask for recommendations I think that was
uh
uh also someone earlier said they just
finished volume one of something is
killing the children it makes me very
happy and a half okay so apparently
you're reading Superman and you've read
All-Star and kingdom come so we want
recommendations for Superman I would
also recommend uh Man For All Seasons uh
I think it's a really good approachable
run that doesn't have a lot of
continuity tied to it that they're gonna
lean into for the movie's inspiration in
tone I would also recommend Superman
blue which is a Jeff Loeb and Tim's sale
book Jeff lope and Tim sale do these
really great books with colors tied to
them they did um uh Spider-Man uh they
did a really great uh they did Batman
along Halloween they did a really good
Daredevil yellow they're a really
beautiful team and the Superman I really
think exemplifies in five or six issues
like the heart of the character I'm
currently really really enjoying the uh
John Kent run that is happening the Tom
Taylor issues one and two that just
started I'm not digging as much because
it's leading to Titans we haven't really
gotten there yet but the one that just
ended with John Kent was great and also
showed a lot of great Khalil stuff uh I
would also say in the world of Superman
the stuff that uh tied into the first
volume of Naomi gave you a really cool
perspective on Superman not of the lead
of the book but the ramifications of
Superman existing so if you want like a
World building around Superman the Naomi
stuff's really good if you want to play
full book if you want a book that's like
irreverent and less like heady I think
uh Superman's pal Jimmy Olsen that
wrapped up I think two years ago 12
issues it's like an old school comic
like like comic uh in the newspaper
where it's the continuity is insane it's
wacky hijinks and Superman's an element
of it but it's really into the heart of
Jimmy Olsen and the world metropolis and
it's one of the more fun Comics I've
read in years so those five I think
would be good for you six seconds to go
why does anyone ask me about my comic
recommendations and I mean Now's the
Time someone someone well I oh we're out
of time oh that is oh otherwise we
had so many ready you were at the go
hey I just read all of Attack on Titan
that's in except though to the episode
it just that just came out I I
essentially stopped reading right before
I got there so I literally have one more
volume of reading and that's a lot and I
could know how the story ends but I'm
like I'm waiting until the final thing
comes out and I have read it all in like
a month I waited like six months for the
last episode of this is us because I
didn't want it to end so I get it
there's like that preserving your last
well I I'm like as I write to on patreon
and I'm like I don't want to know what
happens at the end I want to react to it
um Dan v900 does some great wrecks too I
really love um The tomasi Run
birthright's incredible and I think
James Gunn loves it as well and then
secret origin uh I think will be like a
a I know we're over time but up in the
sky I was also referenced that's Tom
King who wrote one of the best Batman
runs of all time and is the writer for
Supergirl the one that they're actually
directly adapting so I think up in the
sky is going to give you a tonality
that's gonna be really important and
it's an anthology series you only can
read like one issue you could read all
of it it's a beautiful contained Adam
kubert art
that might have been his brother Andy
Either Way Cupertino Asian Lee you know
sometimes
you might have
one cow out of the cattle but you don't
wanna
feed like the whole cattle if there's
only one cow
I don't understand this McConaughey
reference
one cow outside the pasture now it's on
Wilson
wow cows asianly Scott Atkins is
Deathstroke solo film that is a solid
ass pick yeah got kicks he's a stunt man
I think it would be great and Scott
Atkins is he British in real life I
don't know because he does so many
accents well I think he's Australian
maybe New Zealand okay I interviewed him
with John Wick and I don't know if I can
place it in my face what accent that was
I did not pick up that that was Scott
Atkins is in the suit yeah yeah he was
standing I didn't know it and then the
poster was behind him and I like I
eventually was like
when he started kicking I was like okay
this guy's definitely in a fat suit
because not that like like people like
the obvious references Samo hung who is
like very overweight you can do all the
kicks and so I'm not saying if
you're like really overweight you can't
do the high kicks and stuff but there
was something about it I was like oh
definitely in a fancy well because the
the height of where it had to be was
different like the physical but he was
such a character yeah you know that I
was British all right actually
goth I love that idea Gotham is
Reckoning wow
Owen Wilson is base oh wow look at them
I will break the back look at the
football stadium oh my heart that's how
big it is
uh x-tax lay Taurus txx back in the chat
thank you so much Russo Brothers to
direct Teen Titans movie they seem to
have grasps on directing big Ensemble
movies thoughts that would be a
departure I think I'd rather see him to
do a Titans than a team titan I feel
like a Phil Lord and Chris Miller would
be oh I would love that yeah Chris McKay
was supposed to do a Nightwing movie
forever and he did Lego Movie
exceptionally so I and he also did
Renfield I would love to see uh that
vein of Teen Titan but I don't know
about the russos personally
um I mean that is that is community like
the community element like if you want
the Teen Titans maybe a little older
like college age like Community yeah but
I I would love to see it just to know
what it felt like
yeah I would still go for the Lord and
Chris Miller for that that would be fun
I'd love to see them you know we know
who should direct that uh the people who
did Dungeons and Dragons oh yeah I
haven't seen that movie John Francis
alien jungles I've seen their other
movies and I I feel like they would be
amazing they're very much in that vein
they did clouds and chance meatballs
which Phil and Lord haven't selected uh
whoa really I saw I I think I think uh
what's that called end game yeah game
night uh game night yeah and horrible
bosses they did not direct but writers
on yeah I think they wrote cloudy too
and I think Phil and Chris directed it
but I'm not anyway they're that vain I
agree I would I would love to see them
direct those uh dude I think they'd be
great for like a Teen Titans yeah
um Haskell 420 oh wow wow
well Haskell 420 says my fantastic
forecasting two years ago read Ben
Barnes or Dan Stevens go both good
looking with the other for Doom
shoe storm put a shoot of armor around
the world Emma Roberts he's gone
bending Jesse plemons as a Johnny and
Dylan O'Brien oh Jesse plemons would be
a fun pick yeah that would isn't that
game night comedy would be nice I want
to see you back in comedy but I think
Jesse Blevins is so funny dude he was in
Jungle Cruise the most enjoyable movie
I've ever seen the other side of water I
have never never enjoyed a movie more
than Jungle Cruise ever
I really did not like Jungles I could
tell I had it was it was one of those
moves I'm like that is so loud that's
the only thing I recall and then a weird
ass plot character reveal about Dwayne
Johnson's character I was like where the
did this come from this is really
bizarre it's a weird one it's an odd
Journey you know I like that movie yeah
I don't remember it which is not a good
sign
Ben bards would be a great Doom in the
same ways he'd be a good Batman very
similar sure like I like that a lot yeah
definitely uh Robert does Sue storm I
don't know about that although I do love
American Horror Story and I love
everything she does on that but she
usually just plays like
itchy because right I don't see storm as
having any arrogance because Reed has so
much arrogance that she has to like
apologize for him right like she's the
one going I know he's frustrating and
she's diplomatic and like so I feel like
if there's two arrogant true I'm right
there with you koi son and I love Dylan
O'Brien and everything Simon's lost a
lot of weight ah gross I hate that
I hate when actors he is married to
Kirsten Dunst I know oh my God
Spider-Man Haskell 420 already did you
video Club random thank you for me
Rachel bras nahan would be the perfect
lowest Lane but it also depends on how
you own the cast Superman why can't she
be older than him yeah why can't she
let's face it she's gonna out he's gonna
outlive her anyway
she will be old one day it's gonna be a
reverse Aragorn and Arwen situation my
last two girlfriends earlier than me
it's okay
my wish for when my wedding was to redo
the scene in the woods in Fellowship of
the Ring oh that's beautiful I love that
that's adorable and well she was not for
it
um and I was like it won't cost that
much money I mean it is a day for both
some sort of compromise and he's been
made uh she's from maisel Marvel Smith
is amazing oh so you already know her
yeah of course she's a big fan of
everyone you know why you know her guess
why I'm gonna say we're ready for you to
say it because she's a wife there it is
uh I know her because I love Amy Sherman
paladinos right oh you know her because
she's white also that Amy Sherman
Palladino writes the hell out of
marvelousness look at this whiteness I
mean she's always embracing it
uh if you haven't seen marvelous Mrs
maisel you should it's spectacular I
think should be great Lewis Lane she's
very well spoken she's articulate she's
very good at conveying intelligence
which is a huge factor in the Pulitzer
prize-winning Lois Lane uh and I do
think she's got the the vibe of like
Silver age classic like she's got a a
glow about her I think she'd be great I
would love to hear you say that about a
non-white person one of these days
we're at it again
not casting a romaniac there is Doom or
at least trying is a goddamn mistake
against this great nation Doom's mother
is Romani whatever it makes sense to do
that
weird not to do it I guess so I guess I
don't know how upset with the remaining
community be can we silence them can we
ignore them and maybe like just ignore
them they're not that vocal
I uh I once cast the kid from uh
Umbrella Academy as the half uh
Romani character in Damian Wayne and the
internet didn't let me forget it did you
just the worst so everyone keeps
track of everyone's race specifically
not speak on any racial everyone has to
23andMe before their cast from now on
part of the process that's the new
covert test program
it's like we're gonna need you to do a
23 meter gotta make sure that's the new
protocol I just I won't comment further
that's just what I believe that's that's
how we should do it man that would be
awesome oh my God I love it I think she
had Emma Watson in there somewhere too
you said the biggest crush on her I used
to be like Emma I got a dilemma you spit
wraps at her and now the restraining
order has been extended
um
let's see here Jacoby B Betty Gilpin for
Sue storm she's buff her and glow in the
hunt in her recent show on peacock Mrs
Davis she'd be perfect I think Betty
Gilpin would be a solid choice for storm
actually don't know anybody
no Betty Hawaii
you know look at me not knowing uh yeah
she was mentioned earlier for someone
else and I did not uh please
oh that new show the the AI show
um that Amazon's doing right is this the
same person
oh she's a cool look
koi I got you covered appreciate it
appreciate it let me just uh remove this
live chapter okay and I'll slide her
into frame for you buddy so you can get
a good solid look everyone and who is
this person she play uh Sue storm oh
yeah I can totally see that yeah I mean
I don't know her uh like how she speaks
which is a huge part of I think that
character but I don't know uh well look
here's her as a nun yep range
here's here's her on uh the Jimmy Kimmel
show glowing
here's her uh dramatically at a con
range
um here's her laughing with Stephen
Colbert talking politics probably
laughing at Trump unless you're wearing
a red dress
uh I don't know her work but I I think
like you know that'd be good
oh my God Aisha Kenya back in the chat
thank you so much Jody Turner Smith is
Storm hot stuff you know Jody Turner
Smith
she's so good in uh the that love story
um with uh Daniel kaluya
um light on the compliments and
knowledge here when it comes to a person
of color no I forget that it was a it
was a beautiful movie that was really
intense from like two years ago Daniel
kaluya's in it it's why I wanted him
a thing that's going to be able to call
it in Chase I love this actress and
you're giving me crap yeah you're very
much I'm not calling Joseph wrote this
I'm just surviving on the internet uh
and I think that she has a really really
cool presence to her she's also Wicked
tall which I've always seen storm
especially like the Jim Lee era storm is
like very tall and Regal uh she's
actually someone that was on my uh
shortlist before
um cup uh Cop Shop was the one that um
Gerard Butler did I think I mean uh no
her Queen and slim thank you uh this uh
actress and the Cop Shop actors are two
of the ones Alexis louder is the Cop
Shop actors are two of my storm
shortlists I think she's fantastic yeah
Queen and Slims really slept though I
thought that movie's badass she's cool
sweet good to see here good to see I
like it koi I'm so happy for you oh the
tomorrow award Gilman that's why she
looked Vaguely Familiar I did see that
well I gotta adjust the stream everyone
all right we're almost done here
I don't believe you
we've gone too long coy
it's time for the Jedi to end
you were the tropes
uh there we are yeah
are you all excited for the Barbie
Hammer weekend Heimer weekend watch for
Mouse Austin howdy
well
I'm very much excited for that Barbie
Heimer weekend gonna go out there Shoot
My Revolver up in the sky while riding a
mechanical bull then hopping over to a
real bull that's what we do here for the
Barbie Hammer weekend what's Barbie if
the guy give a he said he's from
Austin I don't know what the hell of
Barbie Heimer I think it's a shooting
I'm trying to be heimers I'm trying to
make Barbie Heimer feel exciting okay
Barbie Heimer well God damn it we're
gonna look up Barbie Heimer for you I'm
really curious because it's got a hyphen
in it and it's also uh we gotta make the
super chats count we gotta mean it gotta
make the super chats Camp what's Barbie
Heimer don't worry koi I got you covered
let me know
you mean Heiser
what is
what is it oh Oppenheimer and Barbie
right Barbie and Oppenheimer weekend is
that what it is because yeah
I thought we were doing some special I
was so I was like there's apparently
like a person
thing here you were talking about
riding a bull
um Barbie and Oppenheimer weekend uh I
think is going to be one of the greatest
weekends of all time because I don't
know which one I'm gonna see first but
I'm gonna double them up and I'm gonna
see them both same day I want a double
feature present watching often I'm gonna
do my best to get an early screening for
Oppenheimer I I'm so excited for both
Barbie looks so good every trailer I
actually skipped the last trailer
because I wasn't here to cover it and I
was like I cannot watch this because I
know I'm gonna see this movie ASAP uh
these are two that I'm gonna fight for
premieres for but if I don't go and I
see it at a regular time Thursday eight
Thursday at 10. Barbie Heimer I mean
they're two very different audiences
that that I'm both though I know I'm the
Venn diagram I'm so excited for both I'm
a Barbie Heimer I am admittedly more
excited for Barbie that I am for up and
I'm a little bit more excited
I just love Ryan Gosling so much he's so
fun so do I
um and seemingly it was a Ken doll is
going to be great uh like I really want
to see him get to like play don't get me
wrong like Oppenheimer looks awesome and
looks like great Nolan but and I
love my IMAX experiences
but Barbie looks like the film where
you're just gonna have a blast I just
think I need more joy in life like the
world sucks I think openher is going to
make me feel heavy enough and Barbie's
gonna make me feel light so maybe maybe
I'll see Barbie fur I mean off a number
first and then like the palette
cleansers Barb it's your perspective Coy
get a million subscribers
that's all it takes is the million
subscribers ask anyone I know on Tick
Tock they're the happiest J mood Z
thanks for being here thank you Kiana
for that sorry for butchering the Austin
accent but I believe I nailed it
speaking of Austin I'm gonna reveal
something to you guys I had to turn down
a press event koi knows not the biggest
fan of doing them unless I really want
to do it I'm not the biggest fan of
doing them and I turned down most of
them knows how long it is
um but I got invited to some but I have
my live event where we've already sold
tickets for it for May 7th for Guardians
I got invited
and I email them back like you have no
idea how bummed I am so turn this down I
got invited to go to Austin to go to
Robert Rodriguez's
Studio spent time Rob Rodriguez and
interview the cast of hypnotic dude and
you know who the cast of hypnotic has
and I had to turn it down because I was
like this is happening the exact day I
already have live event tickets sold for
and I can't I just can't everyone that
hurts I feel that I I I'm a man of my
word and a man of my commitment who's in
Rodriguez's new movie actually don't
know
no you gotta turn down a Ben Affleck
meet yeah oh dude if I wasn't traveling
I'd take that real reject spot it was
about oh that's okay yeah dude that is
intense yeah oh I'm sorry for you all
right that's why we're pajamas yeah just
out of sorrow but soon we'll be Barbie
heimering and else I think it'll be good
again I love everyone casting crime
Gosling for us as sorrow
um someone asked in the chat uh What uh
to Wanda there's a new Scarlet Witch
comic that only started four months ago
it's on Issue four pick it up it's great
J moods I would love to see the
character blood win in the DCU honestly
I think he's perfect for Gods and
Monsters have you heard of him Fan cast
I would love it Jay moods
do you know what it is no actually no no
blood wind
I'm being honest pure I cannot know
thanks Greg let me look him up I'm
deducting your pay every character I
don't know I lose a little bit more
people embarrassment he looks like
morbius
he's got a big red cape and black okay
let's see blood wind uh a necromancer in
DC he starts in jail that's Nicholson it
is thank you Jay Moose for the Super
Chat interesting
I'm sorry bloodwind
I'm back
pandemic jokes I'm sorry we don't know
we'd love to elaborate
unfortunately we don't know we don't
know the guy
but my buddy Jamie Hall apparently
played him in something because it says
played by Jamie Hall now I feel bad
twice it's good that it's good you make
koi aware now he'll get a bunch of
knowledge on it pandemic Jones how
awesome was meeting Keanu Reeves and
what were the highlights of your guys's
conversation with him I reeked I did a
whole recap of it in for in depth here
we spent like 10 to 15 minutes on it
actually pandemic it's you I would love
to recount it
um I feel like Kiana's and everyone's
Buckle lists I mean I'm definitely
jealous much love what I will say is
that it was one of the highlights of my
life it was all thanks to koi that I got
to meet him and they said something
where we might be able to get the
footage so yeah hoping we can get the
footage and I could just show you guys
um how awkward of my phrasing
and incomplete sentences was admittedly
didn't stalk smoothly I think you did
better than you think and it'll be
fighting for you to see it because
you're in phase two of this yeah I
definitely was like I don't I didn't
finish my question but I think he got
where I was going
um so yeah but pandemic thank you for
the Super Chat and um but we did we did
I think it's in the first hour if that
helps but definitely in the first hour
um but yeah we're definitely really
covered it a lot Freddie Ruger we're
we're exiting soon so better late than
never
um but yeah send me a message on patreon
I'll talk more about it pandemic he's
one of our top patrons Jeff Carroll
thank you for Coy because he loves gray
man I saw it on a plane and laughed out
loud when Evan screams got so I got shot
in the ass Suzanne definitely annoyed
the people around me but it was
hilarious I think great man is the 90s
movie I wanted I don't think they make
uh like the Shane black type movies
enough and I definitely got buddy cop
Vibes even though it was like antagonist
protagonist Vibes but like Ryan Gosling
got to be comedic while being an action
star Chris Evans got to do something
besides cap I really thought it was a
fun like romp Global spy thing I I what
I got was what I wanted at a gray man
and no one else really likes it but I
did I'm glad you at least got a joy out
of it I thought it was okay
I definitely had my issues with it and
you're playing quite a bit
you know me greggo is complaining
nollie's upset
Mandalorian finale I haven't watched
your reaction yet but I hear I hear you
pandemic I promise is of uh I'll message
you on patreon with the time oh he was
watching The Covenant I'm so excited to
see that that's Jake Gyllenhall Guy
Ritchie movie I want to see that real
bad oh I wonder if Netflix is already
saying it's now number one streaming in
the world is that a Netflix movie I
think it's in theaters I think it's a
Netflix movie huh I think because I was
gonna go sit in theaters on Monday I
hope you think this guy just popped out
really quick to go to the theaters yeah
and then be like all right I'm back here
in the Stream it's Saturday
I think he's probably one of the movies
I don't I legit think it's a it's a guy
Richie jigsaw in the theaters or is it
streaming I think I think it's theaters
I'm pretty sure it's streaming
all right let's watch it I'm pretty sure
it's streaming
oh can I just do this
I can power oh the final super let me
confirm
let me confirm
I think we got a super sticker oh
my Kalinowski loves the gray man good
man Mike you're going down Mike
Kalinowski it is in the theaters yeah
that's right uh Pedro Pascal is a doom
is an interesting choice I I kind of
want Pedro to get to like play a bit
more because I feel like he's now Gotten
Trapped in like the I'm a good guy a
little rugged and I'd love to see him
get to do something else he's got his
range she's shown it no no but I wanted
like his next franchise I want to be not
as the same thing like the next thing
you do would be cool to see him as Doom
to mix it up
um yeah I mean I think the first thing I
saw him in was
weird like kingsman the Golden Circle
it's one of the first things I remember
him in I feel like there's stuff I just
didn't like remember but yeah he's been
in the game a lot
Terry O'Quinn is Doom I love that
actually
that could work unitario Queen from Lost
stranger things
which one is he
am I thinking of the right actor
let's see let's all Google it I thought
he was
um uh the main guy in stranger things
The Rocker guy no definitely definitely
what is the act Joseph Quinn
is a very different man yes yes it is oh
you're talking about Eddie Munson yeah
yeah
can you think of two more different
people than Eddie Munson I am the guy
who lost the last name Quinn Coy don't
act like it's I just love that
you picture no but your imagery was like
oh that's interesting and then like this
is the guy that comes up like the
difference in Dooms who is the oh that's
so this is the guy who doesn't blink
with the wide eyes and lost uh creepy
guy he's on that show with uh Jesus
Christ now um cavizel yeah yeah is that
person of interest he'd be a decent
Doctor Doom
I feel like I feel like Dr Doom cannot
be 30 years older than uh Reed
um so uh because if they cast like you
know late 30s you're talking about
so I mean I I think he's a good actor I
just don't know if he'd be a good dude I
think he'd be a fine Doom he's the last
thing Joseph Queen would be fine raccoon
shampoo I'm here to say yes to anything
boy I don't give a don't don't let
her I would just can't be a say don't
turn your expectations don't turn your
speculation into expectation Toby's dick
Toby Maguire's dick was not in
Spider-Man no way home
um holy I totally I've turned this
into chaos oh it's chaos raccoon shampoo
thank you for the sticker now you can
see the stickers loud and clear and it
says bump thank you so much my friend
thank you raccoon and then we got one
last stream Lab to take care of
koi I round up for the other stuff all
the time you mind if I just round this
totally even three today talking
business on camera yeah
no man
weren't exactly it out
I expect that in decimals
Julian
I would like to see a red wolf in MCU
who is the red wolf koi uh I believe
this is actually I'm gonna make sure you
don't know nothing I'm gonna make sure I
want to make sure I'm right because uh
blood wind made me embarrassed and
Afraid so I'm just gonna make sure
before I say anything in the internet
that's gonna Gonna Keep Me in trouble we
have different chemistry than you and
John uh well we're different people you
know in my life I typed in red wolf and
I got a wolf
okay so it was who I thought it was uh
red Wolf's a newer character uh not like
super new but it was utilized recently
in a really cool uh mini series that I
really liked by Edmondson
um it is a character that's Native
American we don't have a lot of Native
American characters in the uh in the
movies oh my god do we need them I mean
it's an entire group of people there all
right then I say yeah put them in there
systematically destroyed uh and I I
really like that his uh powers are are
grounded with Supernatural elements and
I think that's something Marvel's
missing right now is their Supernaturals
really big and they're grounded's really
contained I think it'd be a good Middle
Ground um so I think it'd be a cool
story to tell and could also do like a
great special presentation with them so
I meant I think it'd be great hold on
everyone's get a good look at everyone
don't want us to leave the screen okay
we're just little all right so then like
super close to the camera this guy has
even cast is who we need to cast red
wolves
okay good we did it
what a stranger can we go over tinier we
can
I want people to tune in right now so
like what is this show this is the
quality someone also wrote this is like
a marvelous realm fan image like we're
just making it real like someone's gonna
say like real rejects confirm casting
this is my favorite chaos guys chaos all
right guys we're gonna return it to the
original now we're gonna bring It full
circle as we wrap this out
and now that Coley agreed to round down
we're gonna go on here for an extra half
hour
because time to yep there it is
you know what maybe there's a way to um
maybe I can meet this halfway here I'm
gonna go reset transform a lot of
experiments oh someone just said hello
they're just joining as we leave
sorry K1 we're out of here soon streak
koi
put us here an interesting background
there it is nice nice dental work
excellent teeth good job brushing for
life
I've done well
what are we what are we doing we're
gonna say bye
I'm just making a fun background here
yep no this is this isn't a Troublesome
at all
it's just gonna be
is this your Father's Day wrap up just
this is how I'm doing this as we leave
with Father stew Greg's new favorite
film
there he is just watching over us this
serious smell was Mark father stew or
was Mel fathers do Mark is Father Stu
Mel plays his father oh he's father of
fathers is he grandfathers do well the
thing is uh the movies are hard R I also
like swearing Mill like non-stop
swearing and it's I was surprised I was
like oh my God this is really hard R
Okay and like yeah it gets a little
preachy who the cares
um but I really liked it I mean it's a
Mark Wahlberg Mel Gibson movie I'm gonna
see it because that you know yeah but we
are a star skiing hutch what
yeah when you were like you have
different energy than John I'm like well
yeah we have a lot more
Do It Pop the trunk do it
do it
dude are you Owen Wilson
oh I'm Owen Wilson wow Pop the trunk
it's the only light I remember that
movie it's my Ben Stiller I remember
liking that movie full of energy I
bought that DVD from Blockbuster when
all that club with all the Blockbusters
closed all right guys well listen
are you upset that Mel Gibson's making a
comeback because you shouldn't be you're
just antagonized at toned for his sins
according to his publicist
she could always trust anyway let's see
uh how many people I'm gonna say we
ended this with 100 viewers still in the
Stream I mean you certainly went for a
swing at the end there we we've got it
this is definitely this was one I think
most of these news ones we stay on the
news Yep this was 90 not news I feel
just like right we answer questions
random questions throughout is what we
did we didn't have a lot of news
questions
a very fascinating stream we did but we
could um so thank you guys so much
619 people still watching that is a
staggering amount of people to be
watching and we knocked out all three of
those main topics so no one can complain
not a single person and we eventually
talked about the other ones listed in
the description box for you know uh
viewership purposes on your way out
people if you could leave a like like
that would be very much appreciated last
live chat comment ray of sunshine
thought Mark Wahlberg
random people here in the Stream right
now uh Scott Welsh thank you so much for
being here Cameron sayonara Chell sameli
thank you everyone who contributed super
chass and streamlabs reactions Christian
unpronounceable I mean flow wise thank
you so much till the end of the line
reader if something is killing the
children
was the thing is a great idea the word
about Victoria Alonso as the thing
making her comeback boom Jacoby thank
you so much for being here for as long
as you have been Hunter MK King DK J the
laser Christy DT Gordon random thank you
guys so much this passed out came back
joined us again any last words uh read
Comics watch movies hug your family can
we try something because I've been
running and it's raining like I'm
telling you saw it in the Kiana photo
right that weird ball curl up except
your skin or the gas the skin what do
you got a skin problems what's
the goal here what are you trying to
show guys what I'm trying to show you is
like I told you like before I had a
really ever since as I've lost like 15
pounds incredible almost 15 pounds like
right right there in the last five weeks
wow that's a good speed man but then
I've I've um
I've uh well I'm trying to show everyone
oh God it's weird
pure chaos but now we're just hanging
out okay all right this is official
we're just hanging I like that you're
about to crop out of Keanu I'm gonna
show you guys like really quick
okay so let me put the chat away I got
this thing where with my like with my
arms my elasticity is getting bizarre
here well we're aging but it's only
started happening the last five weeks
when I started losing weight right
because your skin has to catch up and
the skin doesn't go crazy
it's gross that's that's I just lost the
thing I was trying to put here so I
would say take collagen because that
helps skin elasticity it also helps skin
cell growth I want you guys to see this
you see my arm here it's got It's got
not and before it was just a bicep curl
now it's got this weird like Rolling
Hill thing so you know what you can do
okay you see the Rolling Hill thing so
when you look at a bicep Greg this is
this is uh this Gap right here can be
changed by the forearm workouts you do
so like I very potentially some of the
genetic but I also trying to help you
out my point first okay first person you
see it right this weird like like skin
curl up thing that I've NE I haven't had
ever done that's never happened to my
skin before but and now and it's been
happening now so like other parts of my
body yeah it's an elasticity thing it's
also like a right change thing and it'll
go away and also collagen will help go
expedite it but also what you can do for
The Gap that's causing it is like the
types of workouts you do some of it's
genetically like how long your bicep is
but the types of workouts can extend the
bicep so if you do hammer curls so like
when you see your arm like this this is
protracted so hammer curls will make the
bicep longer as well as inverted curls
so you take the like the bar uh the the
dumbbell and hyperextend that'll extend
the length of the bicep giving you less
of a gap which will help like this so
forearm curls are great but also with
dumbbells twist twist I don't do the
twist do the twist and then also hammer
curls will extend the length of the
bicep so the three exercises I do hammer
dumbbell forearm barbell hyper extend
correct I don't even do a forearm oh
forearms are great that's how you get
like these brachials so the brachials
are really good for like t-shirt wearing
and mine is skinny it's not solid let's
get brachials it's very defined but
forearm curls butcher bicep behind mine
[Laughter]
also when you do those kind of curls it
helps your tricep definition you're
trying to get it I'm trying to be there
just trying to be like the buff guys
buff nerd commentary I'm not on my way
to buff I've slimmed down a lot no I'm
not 15 pounds is crazy but if you get
the extension like this that lengthens
the actual bicep it'll help the Gap
because see my Gap is almost negligible
see you got this like big big chunkiness
oh yeah that tricep is
massive dude it's like a tone thing but
God damn yeah the tricep you gotta
really work on so the tricep is gonna be
the biggest part of your arm people
think bicep it's actually like I try
something here but it's like you got
like the weight bolt extender outside so
I do six different tricep exercises guys
damn so you got to do some overheads
that get back here so you're going to
want to grab like the so they're doing
that today yeah these but also do
Kickbacks because that'll give you that
rear center triceps so grab like a
dumbbell and give an extension like that
and then also the machine if you have
those push down machines
so yeah
for free in that look how big yeah yeah
you got like a bulky thing anyway guys
all right I think that's a good spot to
end this stream uh could be weird guys
it's on the internet forever now and uh
we'll see you guys soon
sex appeal man take it off I mean Greg's
in like approaching my shape and you've
done it in like a month dude you're
crushing it it's crazy just uh just
killing myself one day at a time